so representative walner
um pat long is coming in today for
sharon
and
i think they may be tied up in executive
session do you have any issue with us
getting started without pat here
oh good sorry i don't know why i
couldn't afford it i
tried did you interview some more
prisons
yes i did and i got two more of them
not next week
the people that were involved
uh i'll call it one o'clock and um one
o'clock uh i'm going to convene
this session on
house bill 103 uh we've had some
amendments to it
um i'll start by asking mr ripple uh if
the very last minute
changes i i was asking for were able to
be accommodated by ols
but we have the amendment that was
drafted yesterday along with your
proposed changes okay
okay um
okay so so i'll i'll talk a little bit
about um the context of what we're
what's happened since our last hearing
and then um and then we'll bring the
department forward we'll probably just
have a few questions just to
close things out but
uh
so we're really really close i i ended
up
talking to the senate about
senate bill 422 and by the saying the
senate i actually mean five different
senators
to include the prime sponsor
and
i explained
to the prime sponsor
that in my perception 422 and 103 were
extremely similar to one another but
that 103
had reigned back
um some of what 422 wanted
in terms of uh our
asking for
uh patients to pay a co-pay when they
were able to
and also to carve out the particular
um
patient population demographics that
would be subject to receiving uh
dentures the fort 422 the senate version
was
open to every beneficiary and they had
no co-pays
we
uh liked their fifteen hundred dollar
annual cap so we took it in our
amendment and we also liked their use of
the centene funds
that we used
in our version
the distinction in the centene
settlement funds and our version is that
there
mr ripple would you would you remind me
of the the term for the 2.4 million
dollars that there was something about a
risk corridor right there was 2.4
million dollars for a risk corridor
settlement which the department would be
able to explain in better detail than i
can but it was basically for
uh overpayments
that the federal government made because
of
uh
flawed pricing methodology on the part
of centene that the state now owes back
to the federal government
okay so thank you for that so so since
uh we had no hearings in the house on
the risk corridor issue
we
took that we excised that from 103
and we reduced the amount of the
settlement we would lay claim to by the
2.4 million dollars that way the risk
corridor issue can stand on its own
and maybe maybe what could happen is sb
422 would would get amended down to
where it was just a risk corridor bill
you know potentially
so uh so that that that those
discussions were held with the prime
sponsor and several co-sponsors
and i and i think generally um
the the
i could expect the senate to support hb
103. we'll see how that all plays out
but that that would be my
prognostication
as i was going through the amendment
that um
mr ripple had prepared on our behalf um
the edwards irf amendment uh
two zero two dash
hotel
um
i
i reread it and
what seemed to me to be missing that i
had never really noticed before
was there there was no discussion in the
statement of purpose
about the importance and the primacy
of individual responsibility to take
care of their own oral health
so
mr ripple has gone down to ols
very late in the game because i was very
late in the process
and for example on page one line eight
we would add
that in addition the general court
recognizes that personal responsibility
is an essential component of any
strategy to improve individuals oral
health
without that statement you can almost
imply
that it's the state's responsibility to
take care of people's oral health
without acknowledging
that first and foremost it's an
individual responsibility so i i don't
think this is a controversial addition
i just think that it it tells a fuller
story
and for anyone wanting to compare 422
and 108
this sentence could help them understand
that the house version is placing
relatively slightly more emphasis
on the personal responsibility of
individuals to care for their own oral
health there were a couple other
minor edits
like on page 1 line 19
i'll give you a second to find it
we added
in the existing list of goals the goal
of fostering individual behaviors that
promote good oral health
also on page 1 line 26 and 27
uh
we added to the list of states needs
patient education
on page two
line four
we again similar added patient education
and um
i i think this actually just
completes and rounds the circle
because we already had included in
the the specific deliverables of the
contractors
the fact that they needed to um
where is it
that on line 26 of page two it says that
they were to conduct behavior management
and smoking cessation counseling so so
we had already anticipated the need for
patient education to be in it this this
just makes sure that the framework
supports
the specific thing that we asked for
so um
so i i don't think those are
controversial additions they're just not
in the amendment that we have before us
is is there
is there any discussion on that i i'm
hoping everyone at least has mr ripple's
change document
and we're able to follow along
is
is there any discussion by the committee
because what i'd what i'd like to do is
is get through hb 103
and then recess us because we're going
to have a long session on hb
1677 and hope that ols can complete the
work and then we can just vote on
the the latest amendment uh this
afternoon that's that's what i'm
thinking we'll do
uh representative rogers representative
walner do you have any
yes representative walner and you need
the mike
thank you
um i just wondered i assume that you we
have run this all by mr littman to be
sure that this works for the department
and in his contracting it works
so i'm going to go with a partial yes on
that and then i'll explain the partial
yes is that that he's he's seen
uh the amendment and so has dr finney
seen the amendment zero eight six eight
hotel and and they've
i've gotten word
through i think mr shapiro that you got
a representative shapiro that you guys
were good with at
the the the new new thing that's a
little bit of a surprise to you
is the new language i had added about
including personal responsibility for
your oral health and as i was reading
and i was watching
your body language seem to be saying yes
but i don't want to assume too much
so do you want to come up to the and
introduce yourself
good afternoon for the record henry
lipman medicaid director
good afternoon sarah finney
medicaid dental director
uh thank you have you
did did mr ripple hand you a copy of my
changes here these words he did um
i i know it's a little um
quick
but
do you have do you on its surface do you
have any issue with adding these this
terminology
none i think it just
solidifies as you explained um all the
way through
what the intent is and
i think we can work with it for sure
do you follow
no no thank you okay thank you are there
any other questions i i just want to
keep it focused for now on the
additional supplement i i would add to
the language on individual
responsibility
okay so so seeing none
um
we can we can get into
the amendment itself
and i think we we did a pretty good
review and that um
what the changes are from last session
uh is is the addition of the comments
that that we made during that session
like we included the centene settlement
for example uh we included the fifteen
hundred dollar ceiling right
uh pardon
me the 1500 was already in there
oh all these added was the centene the
appropriate you change the
appropriations
part to reference a corporation the
centene settlement rather than just an
absolute dollar amount that's okay so
thank you for that um
so
i want to i want to go to page three
lines six through eight
and
i i want to touch on something that dr
finney shared with us in testimony last
week
last week
you mentioned a specific number you said
that anyone that was over a hundred
percent
uh poverty level would would pay ten
percent of the bill
all right so so just as i'm reading
lines six through eight i don't see
ten percent called out as an as a number
and and so i would just want to hear you
explain how
this language means ten percent
in in line six um you have to the
maximum extent allowed under cms
guidelines
and that is currently the maximum
allowed and obviously
if we have to follow
the statute there we would
we would if it increased or decreased we
would have to follow that but it's been
consistent for for a long time
it hasn't changed and i don't i'm not
aware of any changes in the offing
all right i assume that but i didn't
want to assume it so then the other
thing i had a question from the other
chamber
about
annual renewals and and i believe dr
finney
said this in testimony last week but
because i was asked by a senator i just
want to double validate this
what the process would be as i
understand it is that
incomes would be certified annually
and that we wouldn't go back for
recertification
until the next year
so that if there were a change of
incomes in in mid-season
they would continue to
pay out
uh under
their previous um
enrolled amount is is that true
go ahead because you know if i could
take that one if it's okay
so um individuals are supposed to
report changes in
circumstance which would include income
so
for example someone could
who wasn't employed might get a job and
that would change their income and
potentially their eligibility the other
way around could also happen someone
could lose a job and their income would
go down
so um
it is generally um and most
frequently an annual redetermination but
there are can be changes for changes in
circumstance and
um it could be
someone um
had a medical condition that changed
their circumstance so they've went into
a different eligibility group
they could age
like
someone who was a child who's now aging
into the adult
you know in an in-between period that
could change as well
okay so so you actually uh cleared up my
missed thinking on this um
but for the people
at the reception desk who are trying to
collect the money the answer remains the
same to them when the patient comes in
to visit they check the system to check
the status and then
act according to the status in the
system
yes so all of the
changes and you know
their medicaid enrollment status
are you know basically transparent to
the providers it's just what the
department does in background
yes okay
all right
um so that
addresses
the
the additional questions that i had on
the bill are there
are there any other questions
um
[Music]
representative rogers representative
waller
you okay
representative weiler representative irf
representative bean anything
okay so
um so what i think we've achieved
is is i think we've achieved clarity
on the amendment to hb 103 um
amendment 0 0868
hotel
and that
i don't see any
opposition to
[Music]
modifying this language so that it
reflects that personal responsibility is
also a key aspect of the program is
there any opposition to that you know
from the department from anyone in the
committee
okay
so um
with that i uh i think we'll put hb 103
into recess
uh believing that it's possible ols can
deliver a fresh amendment before we
finish hb 1677
this afternoon
so we're on recess for hp one zero three
okay so the status for anyone in the
room who's curious is the next thing
we're going to do is hb
1677. that's in the house calendar at
two o'clock so we can't start before two
o'clock so um the committee
is really on recess until two o'clock
until we hit 1677 have division one join
us
it's uh it's two o'clock and so i'm
going to call this
hearing into session this is the hearing
on
hb1677fn
for those of you who are following along
we are
primarily referring to
the umberger amendment
that's
2022-80891 hotel
keep that distinguished in your notes
you may want to write big on that that
that's the official version and the
reason i point that out is because the
victims council has already has also
submitted a
i'll call it a red line with their
recommendation recommended changes and
so they look similar
you'll want to keep them distinct
the other thing that the victims council
has provided us is a summary of changes
required by the victims council
that's a
a bullet list of 10 items
we're going to walk through that um
in in in discussion
um i think i think
i think there may be four
additional items beyond the ten
brought up by the uh
council
uh that we're also going to talk about
so
what could very likely happen given the
the number
of recommended changes before us
and given that the finance committee
needs to know our position
on the 8th of march
i i think we're going to end up going
through everything we can today
come into as much agreement as we can
today
and then recess
until thursday
at 2 p.m
the reason we're starting at 2 p.m
instead of earlier that day is our our
chairwoman has a
medical appointment
and we want to make sure she gets to
that and can come join us before we wrap
up
so so that's kind of my overview of of
where we're at and what i think we're
going to do today it's going to be
walking through
the list of 10 items plus four
and um
and we're going to have a show of hands
one moment
we're going to end up having a show of
hands at each of these bullet points
just to get a sense of the committee on
where we're at because we need to give
guidance on what changes to incorporate
and which ones we won't so
representative rogers you have a
question
thursday the third you want to meet at
two o'clock you said
yes ma'am okay and how long do you have
an idea of how long you think we'll be
here then
well i i i think that we could finish in
90 minutes or less and the reason i
think that is because
we'll we'll have done the discussion and
straw votes
today
and then come thursday
at
the third at 2 p.m
at that point we're just validating that
the
that ols has crafted a version that we
can pass to the finance committee so so
i don't see a lot of discussion on on
thursday afternoon
thank you
okay
so before yes ma'am yeah um
if we could i would like to have
the changes that
kevin and mike have been working on
that deal with finance
to let them go through those before we
start on this
if that's okay
or whenever you want to do it but we did
make some
financial
changes to the bill not not in the 100
million but in how we're
getting the money and so on
okay
the reason i look confused is because
i'm just a little confused um i i i was
prepared to go
through the
10 items presented by the victims
council plus the four items we talked
about in caucus right okay is there is
there another
stack of things that we need to talk
about
just a couple of things
oh okay okay could you tell me again
what they are mr ripple had some
financial changes and are those
reflected
in this document that we have before us
the umberger amendment zero eight nine
one are they in there are they elsewhere
they're in there
all right so uh mr ripple do you want to
go ahead and take
center stage and
or mike do you either wanna mr hoffman
yes i will i'm mike hoffman by the way i
work with the legislative budget
assistant
the amendment before you number 891 h
incorporates all the changes in the last
version that the ag presented on
thursday
plus three other items
the first item is
that the
attorney general
maintains control of the fund
the second item provides language for
reimbursement to other agencies
for costs that are incurred
and the third item is that the
appropriation instead of coming from the
general fund would come from the rainy
day fund
so on page one
in the area of line 13
the administrator previously it read
that the administrator has management of
the fund that's been removed there
on page 2 line 15 it reads that the fund
should be administered by the attorney
general
then on lines
17 through 24
most of that's new the fun should be
non-lapsing continually appropriated to
the department of justice
on line 17
then on light 18
the fun shall be non-lapsing and
continually appropriated to the
department of justice until june
at which date the fund should lapse to
the revenue stabilization reserve
account instead of the general fund
that's the
formal name for the rainy day fund
then the following line
used to read that the administrator
would
make the determination of whether it's
when the fund is discontinued and this
is added to
allow for consultation between the
attorney general and the administrator
the next sentence makes it clear that
the settlements will be paid according
to the process laid out in the bill
and then
the last sentence provides that the
attorney general may enter into
agreements with the
judicial branch or other agencies to
compensate them for services related to
things performed in accordance with this
chapter
and if we flip all the way to page
eight
on line 23
it reads if the administrator determines
that a shortfall in the ydc settlement
fund is likely to occur the
administrator in consultation with the
attorney general
shall request funds from legislature
similar change on line 35 the
administrator in consultation with the
attorney general shall submit a
quarterly report
then the last changes are in section
four on page nine
that was changed to from the general
fund to the revenue stabilization
reserve account
and the final change is that
any unexpended fund as of 2032
will lapse to the revenue stabilization
reserve account instead of the general
fund
before i'll come to you in a second
representative umberger
it seems to me i i think we also talked
about adding a sunset
provision in here to to close the law
out uh at some point did
did you think about that mr hoffman or
or did we confuse you i think that was
the last item on the attorney attorney
general's
most recent list
and we didn't have any information i
don't know if mr formella has
information on that today
yeah so so our plan with that was just
to see
once we got to the point where we we
thought this was in very close to final
form we were going to draft that
language so
what we after we get through today and
we hear the committee's straw votes on
the various potential changes
we were going to plan to potentially
work with kevin on any last minute
changes
that come out of today i will also plan
to bring some language to
whatever that quick work session is uh
regarding sun setting it just it's got
to be before then
has to be before then because that's the
final thing
the sun
what's the final thing sorry you can't
wait till friday
or thursday oh no i wasn't going to wait
till thursday okay i meant
we were
by work session i meant we were going to
plan and we haven't even told you this
yet kevin bob and i we were going to
plan to get together with you
potentially before thursday just to help
to make sure we iron out any changes
that come out of today and make sure we
get them right since we know thursday
will be the committees for the divisions
final work session
so we'll have that ready before thursday
so so when you say you plan to have this
work group meeting before thursday and
today being tuesday that means tomorrow
yes
well thank you very much uh
go ahead representative amber yes um i'm
sorry i do have one other thing and that
is
um
i've talked to mike and kevin about this
and this is on page two
dealing with how we're going to pay
this
person if it happens to be a retired
judge
uh retired judges
cannot go back into the retirement
system
or
in the i mean they're already in a
medical thing
so we'll have to um
kind of firm up some language in there
that says if it's a retired judge then
you know they don't get the benefits or
will give them the benefits and
you know the same monetary benefits as
if they
were collecting them or you know so
okay okay so the bottom line on your
comment is when you need additional
language to to handle the special case
of of a retired judge just for yeah
that's correct all right
okay
okay so let's let's stay focused on uh
mr hoffman's review of the inclusion of
the three financial elements
are there any questions of the committee
representative walner
thank you
so
i wondered why
what the thinking was behind
using the revenue
stabilization reserve account
instead of
existing
revenues and secondly
i'd like a refresher about how we open
up the
rainy day fund i
thought there were some very specific
guidelines standards around how we move
forward with opening up the rainy day
fund
uh to answer your second question there
are
and that's why this is written the way
it is is to bypass that requirement
so that
the legislature doesn't have to
vote specifically
on
opening the rainy day fund
but rather through this bill
would approve
using the dollars out of the rainy day
fund
do you want to continue that
conversation represent walnut are you
are you satisfied um well i guess i
would like to know
what the thinking is behind using the uh
rainy day fund as opposed to
our
revenues that are coming in our revenues
have been coming in quite strong
and
it seems like
we do have
funds available at this point
part of the thinking behind that if i
could
is that
we currently have about
328 million dollars worth of bills
that are before either the house or the
senate
and that
obviously spend money
and those monies would be coming out of
the
revenue that is over projections
and so we
wanted to be able to um
fund it would limit our ability
to fund some of the
necessary
bills that we have out there and that's
why
we
opted to go to the
revenue stabilization account
may not be the best logic but that was
the logic that i used
great thank you
could i ask one more question
let me just jump into this conversation
and then don't forget your question
so
so i i don't know i'm still a neophyte
in many ways to to the things like the
rainy day fund but it's it seems to me
that given that we're going to be
paying cases dating back decades
that those were liabilities that we
actually accrued long long long ago
and that the monies
from general revenues have added to the
rainy day fund over those decades
and so therefore if we were just trying
to match liabilities to the right
funding stream there seems logic to me
of using the rainy day fund instead of
the current year's revenues
does that pass the common sense test to
you represent lumber absolutely
do you have a question go ahead yeah i
do have no further question i wondered
if there had been any conversation with
ways and means about
the use of the rainy day fund as opposed
to
the um
just regular revenues that we have
coming in
um we have had conversations uh with um
ways and means
uh not particularly dealing with uh what
we what our conversation with ways and
means was is what do we anticipate
the um
excess
maybe that's wrong to the revenues to be
and what would be available
but no i did not specifically
talk to them about
the revenue stabilization rate
are you using the revenue stabilization
money
so
you're you're done then represent okay
so i
i i think i'm going to try
a quick straw vote on this particular
issue just to make sure that i know how
to conduct a straw vote
so
what i'd like to do is ask for a show of
hands and i'm going to ask basically two
questions one is
are you in support of using the rainy
day funds as the source of funding for
for this settlement fund
and then the alternative question is
do you support instead using
current
general funds for that purpose
would that get at your issue
representative walner
um i think so
all right so uh i would like a show of
hands please and um mr uh clerk if you
could just help me with the show of
hands count
um all those who are in favor of using
the rainy day fund to finance
the settlement fund please raise your
hand
clerk counts 10.
those in favor
of using
current general revenue please raise
your hand
the count is 5. so we have uh ten to
five to continue to
to leave the language in for the rainy
day fund
uh i didn't notice any discussion
around um the sec the first two bullets
that we that mr hoffman talked us
through
the control of the fund and and how we
would handle reimbursements are there
any issues there does anyone have any
concern or can i just assume that we're
all okay
go ahead would it be possible for mr
hoffman to again
point me to the right place in the
document
to find that
to find which well i want to know about
the reimbursement to
other agencies
yes the language for re uh reimbursing
other agencies is on page two and it
starts on line 22.
could i ask a question about it please
so um
when you talk about it when it talks
about any
state agency as necessary to compensate
them for services performed
who do you who do you have in mind other
than the attorney general's office
if um
if i might
please go ahead and your microphone's
still on mr yeah okay um there may be
some requirements from health and human
services
to to go back into uh
records that they may have
dealing with the
people that were
incarcerated
i think those that's
that's the primarily primary other
agency that might
require additional funds
if they had to you know
hire somebody to
do that work for them
go ahead
so this probably is more of a question
for the attorney general i what i am
wondering is would you put some come on
up mr formula
it's probably really quick it's either
probably yes or no but um and i can
imagine what it will be um would you put
some limit
on the amount that um another agency was
able to
take from this fun i mean
basically they're it's coming out of the
fund so every time someone gets money
out of the fund
the fund goes down and less for the
victims
so how would you
monitor that yes the goal would be to to
minimize the extent to which the fund is
tapped as much as we could i mean i
think
to represent humber's point that there
could be some additional assistance that
hhs perhaps needed to employ to help
them go through records i mean we would
certainly work and try to identify
any other option that wouldn't require
spending your money out of the fund
first but
you know if we get a flood of of claims
and we had to bring in some outside help
on a temporary basis that would just
leave that option open
the other
the other piece of this that is possible
is that the the administrator has the
option to employ
staff and
it could be and we'd have to work this
out but it might be that the
administrator perhaps might borrow
staff from another
agency but the fund would sort of would
reimburse the agency for that staff's
cost so it
there are a couple of different things
that could play out with something like
that but we would of course try to
to spend as little out of the fund as
possible i can assure you that would be
my goal
go ahead follow up
and i guess my follow-up question would
be will there be an accounting
of that separately so that we can see
how much is coming out
and
in addition to that
um
i mean you mentioned health and human
services which i think
probably backs into
some of the things that were said in the
original fiscal note
and what i'm wondering is i mean that
was an agency that had a 100 million
laps last year
so would you encourage them
to look within their own means first
before they came to this fund which is
really a fun for victims
yes absolutely i mean i'll just say it
here in
since since we're in session
it would be my sincere hope we would not
have to
to tap this money for that purpose
because to your point representative i
think hhs should be able to identify
resources within hhs or shift funding
around within hhs to cover the need i
think what this allows it's just
again
we can't predict the future you know god
forbid we have another kovitz another
covet surge or something and depending
on what hhs is going through if we had
to tap the fund to get him get him a
little bit of temporary help to make
sure we don't end up with a backlog of
claims and have this process go off the
rails that's really what this is for
it's it's a fail-safe
if you will
but it i think it
it makes sense to have it as a fail-safe
even though we'll do everything we can
not that not to use
go it
um thank you for um
that and i do hope that you'll be very
very careful about the use of these
funds because
they are the funds of the victims
yes we will uh president walner i
believe in here there's also a
requirement for
the ag to come to fiscal
with their spent money is it every
quarter yes quarterly reporting so
they won't be privilegedly spending
money
okay
i'm glad to hear that
so representative wallner uh we're gonna
we're gonna be in here for another
couple hours probably
if if uh if you read
lines 22 23 and 24 and and you
want to parse the words slightly
different and throw the word minimal
minimally necessary or something in
there i i i think we could consider that
i don't think it changes what the intent
of the ag is but it may be worth it if
if it buys you peace of mind
no i think that the ag will be very
careful with the funding
all right thank you
so so with that i think we've um can
assume a consensus on the two bullet
points on control and the reimbursement
to other services uh representative
wall's question yeah actually i want to
go back and revisit something
my understanding is let me move this
over my understanding is this is a
meeting of division one and division
three yeah it just occurred to me
afterwards that we've got people from
division two counting
voting i mean i'm sorry voting so we
count their votes and i'm wondering how
that works because
not everybody from division two is here
because they weren't on notice and i'm
wondering why we're allowing
this to be such a lopsided vote when
people from division two are voting when
this is not a division two hearing i i
think that's a very fair observation one
that escaped me um but it's in plain
sight so
so if you are a member of division two
raise your hand please
okay there's representative lynn
and
go ahead representative
yeah representative lin was asked to be
on this committee by you
as a voting member he was not put here
because of him being on division two
so he's been part of this group
okay
and
i just happen to be the chairman of
finance
i don't have to vote
but i felt i could as the chairman
that i can
vote
on any of the committees so
that's
but if it would make you feel better
if it would make you feel better i don't
have a problem not voting
okay
it's so so can i make a request
madam chair that
for the purposes of these straw votes
that representative lin and you
don't vote but i want you to continue to
actively participate with your opinions
and questions and thoughts
but but to represent a wall's vote i i
don't want to make it look like we
packed the court so
so so let's revise the previous um 10 to
or 10 to 5 vote to eight to five if we
that's certainly fine with me all right
and with me
is is that adequate representing walls
it is
for whatever reason the democrats did
not get all the replacements for this
today i i'm not sure people knew there
was going to be voting um but it's it's
it's the way the game is played so i
think it's fair
all right good thank you
so so i'm going to try this a third run
i i think we've now gone through uh mr
hoffman's points on uh control of the
fund's reimbursement to other
departments and use of rainy day funds
and that we're all in agreement with the
language that he's incorporated as a
result
okay
so with that i think
we're ready to move um go go ahead and
represent emmerich
yes i just wanted to we hit a glancing
blow on page 2 lines 32 and 33
having to do with the compensation
and
i i talked to it attorney ramsey about
this last week
and i think it would be
better not to specify
what the administrators to be paid
because this is fixing the salary fixing
the compensation and i i don't that
doesn't give
judicial any negotiating room
so i i think that should be taken out as
you're going through
using retirees or not retirees i think
the position should be defined as a 1099
position which is how i understand it uh
and so they're not going on the payroll
as an employee they're a their
contractor
how that works with retirement i i'll
i'll duck on that one
but i do think you ought to take out
the
superior court justice compensation
because that's now you've got a stake in
the ground that
negates any negotiation with an
administrator
representative walls
well to that end i would
whether we use a judge of salary or not
i'm less concerned about but i'd like
something in there so that you could
have a part-time person because this
isn't going to be a full-time job all
the way through the process can we defer
that conversation because we that's
specifically on the agenda where we're
going to talk about the part-time aspect
of this well it just i'd be happy to but
i just want to say they seem to go
together because if you've got a fixed
judge's salary it's harder to do
a part-time where if you take a
part-time job and put it say i'm an
hourly rate perhaps the same hourly rate
that a full-time judge gets then you can
have something that's more flexible with
the needs of the job that's why i
brought it up now
thank you i i've never hired a judge or
an administrator so i i'd like some
advice from the person that's going to
have to do it what what are your
thoughts on this
thank you representative i
i'm open to that concept i mean from a
recommendation standpoint i i would
recommend that
perhaps we we
do if you're willing to defer that
discussion to when you walk through
claimants council's points because i
think they they kind of address that in
one of their points
either making the person part-time and i
think as part of that to your point
representative emerick i don't see any
harm in say capping the compensation at
what a superior court judge gets so that
you're not paid more than that but
if you're going to have potential for
part time
maybe making that a cap as opposed to
designating that the salary then there's
there's some room for negotiation
so so if we followed your
thought there
we'd be modifying line 32 on page two
and we'd be modifying where it says
the same salary
yes
that it would be capped at no more than
the salary yes
okay
do do you have that mr ripple okay good
any further discussion on that we will
be talking about the part-time issue
the way it is now the uh
there is a judicial retirement system
once you're into it you can't
decide to go and do further work that
isn't entered into that
and
the judges have to contribute 10 i
believe it is to the to the retirement
system and the retirement system
contributes the same and there's there's
a pool of money there that's it's there
is
and i think that's fairly stable in that
one but so if if someone
is hired at a
judge's salary they don't have to
contribute to 10 but they don't have the
contribution going into the retirement
system either
so
there's some adjustment there to figure
out well
you're winning and you're losing on
those deals so
that has to be balanced thank you
oh okay so representative
are you satisfied with what we just did
there
all right so at this point we should
invite uh the victim's counsel up
mr formella thank you for coming up and
there'll be more
i think mr don beard
is it beard or bard or
oh i i was told mr
vinci on joe which was a great relief
wasn't going to be here today
and and the don would be because you
can't see yeah because i can't say his
name is really is what it is
so
so you're you're here to to represent
the summary of the ten bullets
oh fantastic mr chairman uh and thank
you yeah and so we brought two people
give you two names
easier to pronounce than davis
so
um so
i'm jim haydem
i'm with the law firm of nixon peabody
and partner dave's and with me is dan
dean
another partner with us and he's part of
our team regarding the victims
of the ydc abuse and we wanted to tag
team today to try to make this go as
efficiently as could you spell dan's
last name
d-e-a-n-e
and hate them with one t
thank you
there we go thank you
so um
we
as you see in front of you we
focused our
comments to
the
to the draft the last the attorney
general's last recommended amendment
as a way of sharpening the focus
for this meeting i would say
i don't mean to abandon the issues that
dave has raised before but i don't mean
to repeat them here
and we have
we have
stated our position very clearly in
relation to expanding the full scope of
this bill
and there's an amendment that could be
considered if you were to go down that
road based on a prior draft but for
today for today we're going to focus on
specific provisions of the bill
um that we haven't
that uh that seem to be in front of you
um i don't have an opinion about the
changes previously discussed uh relating
to the rainy day fund uh we weren't
really prepared to think about that
today
but certainly as i listen to comments
about
the attorney general
controlling funds
i i don't know where to come down on
that issue but i can i just want to
remind the committee that you know every
day that we do
this bill does things like that you know
the question really is going to become
whether you're actually establishing a
trauma-informed
victor senate alternative to litigation
because
it's where clear that we think this
should be a process is inviting to every
victim not just a select few
um
and
with that
as you'll see on our summary we have uh
two points relating to the physical
abuse
definition
that was added to
to added to the draft last go-around and
for that i'm going to ask dan to
explain
our comments
you know i i want to hear you i just
want to make sure i'm following in in
writing exactly where we are and what
we're looking at i i i see your redline
version are we off of your redline
version or are we off of the last
official version the committee used
we we're working off of our redline
version we we didn't have that uh
okay so so in this in this example on
line 36 you added a single incident of
for example is that where we are yes
that's right okay i won't interrupt you
further
okay uh so
and
i'm actually going to talk kind of in
conjunction about both the first two
points
because there are similar reasons for
these changes it's both to the
definition of physical abuse and
sexual abuse
uh and you know as jim said we're not
going to repeat all the kind of core
principles that david had uh had told
you about in prior meetings but you know
this goes to that kind of core principle
of of covering everyone and being
comprehensive with a alternative dispute
resolution process and we think that's
you know in the claim its best interest
and also in the state's
interest to resolve to the extent it can
to resolve these claims through this
process and not have a situation
not only where you're discriminating
against some members of this class but
there are possibly cases that we
identify in here i can give an example
where you could have a a survivor who is
both making claims under this process
but is also being denied
even though the claim might itself be
valid in court and so they have to then
uh you know they might get a settlement
out of this process but then they still
have to go to court
because some of their claims are not
covered by this um
and and so that's why you know and and
the other thing that i'll i'll point out
too is that you know you've you can see
in the revision we've made on both
physical abuse and sexual abuse as we've
added
reference to the common law definition
of
assault and battery for the physical
abuse
and then
for assault
and then referencing the criminal
definitions
for um
sexual contact and sexual penetration
uh
so
the theme here is
what the state wants to get out of this
process besides trying to make these
survivors whole again or give them some
compensation
is at the end of the day to get a
release of civil claims and civil
liability so we think it is important
that the concept of civil laws
incorporated and not just we're not just
focusing on
criminal statutes
so
let me give you the example
that i think really points out the issue
that we have especially on
the sexual abuse definition
so the attorney general's proposal and
we understand why they did it this way
they wanted to make it
fairly narrow to address this specific
situation their sexual assaults
occurring in a juvenile detention
facility but it it just cuts too too
thinly it slices too thinly
and i think we saw evidence of some of
the complications that causes
during the last hearing when
representative lin had some concerns
about the carve out they had to make
that was caused by the fact that their
their slicing was so thin
so
the example i'll give you is
supposing there's a 12 year old that's
detained at the the at the ydc and they
are
physically assaulted thrown to the floor
and and raped by a janitor
that is going to cause an issue
when uh the administrator has this case
uh the administrator's gonna have to
look at
well uh did this person have direct
supervisory authority
over this victim they're the janitor
they're not a guard they're not a
counselor
and
when you look at the the statute 632
a2
so for felonious
sexual assault
632-a-2
if you have a brutal rape of somebody
that's 12 years old that is very easily
covered by several provisions
of the statute including the very first
provision which is
when a perpetrator overcomes the victim
through actual application of physical
force and physical violence and also
subsection l
when the victim is less than 13 years
old but instead we're asking the
claimant in this in this process
to have to prove n
that the that the perpetrator was in a
position of authority over the victim
and use that authority
uh to perpetrate the rate the the rape
uh and even goes further than that when
the actor has direct supervisory
disciplinary or other authority
authorized by law so these are
this is adding elements and complexity
to the process for
for reasons that we don't understand and
don't seem to be victim-friendly
so um
and you know kind of returning to my my
previous point at the end of the end of
the day we're looking for a release of
civil claims if this claimant
goes to court
they wouldn't have to prove
this whole you know supervisory
authority piece of this they would just
prove i was physically assaulted and
raped
so um you know we we think this process
should mirror
you know what would happen in court if
you're going to get a release of
liability
um
and you know as i mentioned before
you could have the same claimant that
has multiple claims so and and and we've
seen this in the files that we've looked
at we've we have claimants
that are assaulted
and raped by multiple different people
in multiple different positions within
the ydc
so there could be examples where you
have somebody that
wants to go through this process and
they're able to resolve some of their
claims
but they have other claims that they
they have to go to court to resolve
and that would seem to defeat the
purpose of the statute
let me check in with the representative
lin here a second um in an earlier
conversation you were trying to educate
me about the foss language
is is the substitute language that you
developed around
that applicable
here
on on these particular lines i yes i
mean i think i think generally
i don't have
a particular problem with what what
council is saying here with with the
exception that
he
my problem was was carving out that
exception
for the with the false language and
i i note that in in his proposal he can
you he continues to leave the false
language in there which would
carve out that exception which i i think
would make the
make the
the state's liability too broad but i do
agree with him and in fact the way i had
proposed to cover
the situation that the attorney general
had
adopted or i had pointed out was to was
to say that it could be a common law
claim it could be a common law claim
for civil sexual assault so i think
generally i don't have a problem but i i
i would
i would still take out the reference to
accepting state versus foss
um
representative actually i agree with you
on that i i think
if the other changes are are made that
we've requested i think we're fine with
striking that's it's kind of redundant
to
to have that language it's it's not
necessary okay
yeah so i mean i would be okay now
obviously
i speak only for myself
your your opinion matters is is this the
section that she drafted alternative
language i i did mine isn't exactly the
same but
but this is the exact section right it
is the exact section yes
would you would you read verbatim the
language he proposed please sure yes um
what i had uh what i had said was uh in
subsection
uh i
sexual abuse means conduct which would
constitute an offense under rsa 632 a21n
rsa 632 a34
or rsa 632 a43
or a basis for civil liability for
sexual assault
under the statutory or common law of new
hampshire
i
i think that's probably i think it's
pretty close to what you had
from the victim's perspective does that
make sense to you are you could
could you live with that language
so i i guess we didn't have a chance to
prepare but it to answer your question
it does make sense to me it kind of goes
back to
the theme i was saying at the top at the
end of the day the state wants to get a
release of civil liability we're not
talking about prosecuting these people
through this statute we're talking about
uh civil liability so i think going back
to the common law now with
with sexual um with the sexual assault
statute it is helpful the criminal
statute in defining what is sexual
contact
and what is sexual penetration and i
don't know that there's that much
clarity in the common law maybe maybe
there is
but that's why i i still included a
cross-reference to those
provisions um
but yeah i mean
the general notion of this should be as
encompassing as the common law makes
sense to me
and i would just say
mr chairman i i don't with if we took
out the reference to the state free
force case
i i personally don't have any problem
with the way
council has drafted uh the sexual abuse
definition
okay
so um in order to feel like we're making
some progress i i would like to do a
straw vote um
and i guess the straw vote is is really
on item two not item one since we're
talking about sexual abuse and not the
physical piece line
so
so what i would like a vote on is raise
your hand if you think that the
alternative language that representative
lynn has has has drafted we should uh
use that as alternative language to
what's in this now
and then the opposing vote will be
um
we'll have to keep talking about it
go go ahead representative
walls um given that everybody agrees on
the plaintiffs language i'm wondering if
that's the language we should be voting
on
since there seems to be some slight
discrepancy with representative linz but
everybody seems to be in agreement on
the plaintiff's language
i i don't know that i share the
assumption that everyone agrees with the
plaintiff's language i i do
tend to want to defer to a member of the
legislature one draft in legislation
and and he spends some considerable time
looking at this issue
i i don't want to overstate what i meant
by everybody i meant by representative
lin and the plaintiff's attorney i meant
both of them agree that was what i meant
by everybody not the whole committee uh
so but i heard both of them agree on the
plaintiff's language so that's why i was
suggesting that might be what we should
be voting on
so so rather than speaking for you
representative lynn i i i interpreted
you to have distinct alternative
language to what the plaintiff has
offered
yet well
that's true i mean my language is is a
little bit shorter than what council had
had proposed but i as i said before i
think if
the only substantive difference as i see
it is
is that if
if you take out the language the
reference to state versus foss which as
i understand it council agrees that that
he would he would agree with then i
don't really think that there's any
substantive difference between my
language and his language his is
a a little more detailed but i think
substantively the two are the same
so i need to take this down to like the
101 level instead of the 501 level i
just need
which paragraph will go in is it your
position and it's got to be kind of a
binary thing that we should accept the
plaintiff's language or that we should
alt substitute your language is which
one i i would i would use the
plaintiff's language with the striking
out the state versus false reference
thank you representative griffin
thank you mr chairman
i believe that the legislature should do
the drafting and therefore
i would like us to use lepers
representative lim's language and that's
the question you originally raised
and i'd like us to vote on it yes
all right you still you still think that
even though representative lin has
changed his position a little bit made
it okay
we can have we can do that
representative earth did you have a
question i agree with that perspective
okay
so um
we're going to go ahead and do the straw
vote we're going to vote
on bullet two
the show of hands at this point
indicates that you support the use of
representative lens language
uh and then the second vote is going to
be if you
[Music]
prefer the plaintiff's language okay
so
uh
is it clear what what we're doing
okay
raise your hand if you think we should
accept representative lin's alternative
language for this bullet 2 item
so so the clerk counts five um now we're
going to go
the opposite and say accepting
plaintiff's language raise your hands
so that's clerk count six so that's six
to five to go with the plaintiff's
language for bullet too
mr mr chairman uh mr representative are
we still striking the language that
representative lin referred to and if so
i don't know exactly what language that
is that's being stricken
i think what we just said was that we
would accept the language for
lines 39
on page 1
through
page 2
line 1
in accordance with what the plaintiffs
have written
that's what i think we just voted on is
that
correct me if i'm wrong representative
lynn i i think the i the language that i
think
that i understood you voted on and then
got the six
votes was that you would take out the
language that begins on line 40
and and that says accept that coercion
as interpreted in state v foss 148 new
hampshire 209 202
to require an affirmative act by the
perpetrator
shall not be required you take out that
language but other than that it would be
the sexual abuse language used by a
claimant's counsel
so delete starting on line 41 of the
plaintiff's
document where it says accept accept
that's right and then continue the
deletion
until we get to the next page um
to what word the word required
to delete the word required delete the
word required exactly you have a problem
with that
mr
dean
i know that that that works for us thank
you okay so let's let's let's do it that
way without re-voting
thank you
okay
so let's go back to
um
uh mr attorney general did you have an
issue with that
okay i just i don't want to assume i
don't want to
okay
okay thank you um
so i think we skipped over uh item one
though um
uh yes yes uh
so item one uh physical abuse uh
our our edits there are essentially the
same
it's the same concept that we want to
incorporate the common law causes of
action
um
you know in the definition of physical
abuse since again it is the common law
claims that the claimant will be
releasing
any comment from the committee
i say
i i i don't have a problem with the with
what plaintiff has proposed
there either because i think if
something is a common law
there's a common law basis for liability
then that then the state should assume
that responsibility all right and mr
attorney general
so
i don't have an issue with i think
the language regarding including common
law causes of action but
changing the specific offenses to all of
rsa 631
i would recommend at least that full
change because rsa 631 includes things
such as reckless conduct
criminal threatening
you know something like criminal
threatening is not something that i
think
so it sounds like the carve outs that
that are in here for six thirty one one
six thirty one two six thirty one
i guess two is repeated i'm not sure
what that is
to a
you you would recommend that we keep
that and not go to a blanket
yes because that's first degree assault
second degree assault symbol
you know the rest of that
the rest of that chapter or section is
domestic violence reckless conduct
criminal threatening
conduct involving laser pointing devices
no failure to report injuries there's
student losing so i think
i think we should stick with those
specific parts
thank you so um
mr dean mr hayden do you
have any violent opposition to what the
attorney general just said
no i don't think we have violent
opposition it you know assuming the the
common law
uh causes of action for assault and
battery are included i i think we can we
can live with that that change i i think
we're open to the common law
okay so i don't know how to straw vote
this one because it requires me to
remember so i think i think what we're
going to do is we're going to change 36
to read
physical abuse means a single incident
of conduct that would constitute an
offense under rsa
631-1 631-2 or 631-2
alpha
and that is not justified under rsa 627
colon
or a common law cause of action for
assault or battery
okay so we're going to do a straw vote
if you accept the language as i just
read it you'll raise your hand if you
want to do something else we'll talk
about it some more
so show hands do you agree with the way
we just
rephrased it
the vote is 12.
if you're opposed to accepting that
language raise your hand
nobody left okay that makes sense right
8 plus 5 is 12. yeah got it
no no fifth grade i'm still using that
knowledge
uh
so we we've we've gone through one and
two
do you want to pick up uh three now
i do and thank you that's one for me mr
chairman um
so uh
um
uh the comments in
section three are on page two starting
at line twenty 20
and really
the idea of these changes was you know
we wrestled with some of the issues that
represented weil and representative
emrick
discussed in the context of that you
know the folks who are going to be
qualified
to be administrators um and agreeable to
both the attorney general and our firm
are unlikely to be people who are
willing to abandon their career
and become a full-time employee of the
state to run this process
and that will certainly be true in the
early stages as they ramp up
so we thought that
we should add to this bill the
opportunity to
allow for a part-time
administrative
and then frankly
i just made the part-time administrator
as qualified as the administrator that
we've defined
and
later on basically saying that
that part-time
administrator would be paid at the same
compensation rate as a full-time judge
so really to build some flexibility into
this as we move forward and you know
frankly is a way of streamlining the
process i would hope uh to get the right
people in the right spot to so that we
can advance discussions
um after this bill is passed
okay so let's let's uh let's pause there
because we've got a clear break um the
first half of three
asks for the ability to permit a
part-time administrator
uh and earlier we talked about imposing
a ceiling for the salary not not a
description of the salary so if the
committee were to accept part-time with
the ceiling of being paid at the judge
level is that acceptable to y'all
um it is acceptable
okay
mr attorney general do you have an issue
with that are you still back there
oh there you are i moved here just so i
had a microphone just to make it easier
that that's fine with me i think that
makes sense
okay great let's let's put a pin in that
and then move on to the
second
representation burger yes thank you um
if we're going to go to a part-time then
we need to describe how we're going to
come up with the salary
we can't just you know we can say that
if you're full-time you get x
but if you're part-time you get you have
to get y
so so my understanding of that is if we
impose a ceiling anything below that
ceiling for a part-time person could be
negotiated uh is that not adequate by
whom
you ought to say oh by the attorney
general aren't the attorney generals the
gatekeeper to the hiring process isn't
it no the supreme court is
okay okay we the the attorney general
and the um
council submit the names to
this supreme court and the supreme court
chooses whoever
so
we need to have something in there
that says
somebody needs to figure out how much
we're going to pay the part-time person
if in fact
that's
what happens
and oh by the way i don't have any
suggestions okay so
that'll save me that i i to me the the
notion of being able to go to a
part-time
administrator just makes sense in year
three four five in particular um
i i have no idea on how to
set up the language to negotiate a
part-time salary representative walsh do
you have a great idea well i don't know
if it's great but i have an idea
and that is is that you take
the hourly value of the salary and
benefits of a full-time judge and you
compute that out and that the part-time
administrator is paid at that hourly
rate but i think you'd want to include
both salary and benefits the value
thereof
do you have language that you'd propose
um
i probably could create some
um i'm sure anybody else here could too
that's not that hard to create
you know just that the the the the
payment to the administrator shall be at
a rate the equivalent of
the hourly
cost
of salary and benefits of a full-time
judge
it sounded good to me
representative formella did you or
excuse me attorney general i didn't mean
to do that to you general john general
yeah i think claimant's counsel had
started to get at that concept and i
think the one thing we would really be
adding here is that it we're capping it
at the annual salary of a judge but i
think making it so that the compensation
is our at an hourly rate
that's equal and as long as it can't
exceed that what the salary and benefits
would be total i think that makes sense
so i think we can iron out that language
but i think those concepts make sense
so i assume the working group tomorrow
could work out language that meets that
and and i'm i'm i'm going to assume
there's no opposition to that
representative irf go ahead um
then maybe
i don't think i mean it's nice that it's
i understand the calculation but it
shouldn't be a straight hourly rate
period
that basically would put it way over and
it could initially put a way over in the
first year if the guy's working way
beyond 40 hours a week so i think it
should be capped at an annual rate as
well
i i would tend to agree and that's what
i thought we did when we capped it to
begin with
or
represent a lynn yeah can i also just
raise an issue i i the i think it would
need to be very clear
in the definition of benefits
that it doesn't include
the benefits the retirement
benefits
cost of us of a superior court judge
because
you're talking if you if you include
that you're talking about
75 or 80 percent of the judge's salary
for retirement benefits um it's very i
may be a little bit high in that but
it's very high it's it's very high and i
don't i don't know that you want to
include that
health health insurance things like that
that's one thing but the retirement
benefits i think probably not
okay so two things that representative
and lynn have kicked in is that
we
we should have a a total cap i think at
the judge's annual salary and that in
the calculation of benefits
that we would not include the retirement
benefits
the cost of the return the cost of the
retirement benefits
um
so i'll
since you all are going to do a working
group tomorrow i'll let you wrestle with
the details
sure sure
mr hayden
yeah if i got to offer part of the
reason for going to a part-time position
is that frankly these folks aren't
looking for benefits
um you know because they have their
independent law practice or mediation
practice so it's it's not as if
qualified people would really care about
benefits
so um certainly could could say that a
part-time would not be entitled to
benefits mr hayden i think i spoke to
the value of the benefits not the
benefits themselves
i was trying to make the compensation
equivalent that's why i addressed the
value of the benefits
okay all right so i tend to agree with
representative walls on this one so um
but i'll i'll just trust that the folks
with draft and language can figure out
the right way to carve that
um
if there's not any opposition i i won't
do a straw vote
all right so now i i cut you off mr dean
at the second paragraph of three
is that
is that worth talking about
so
it's worth talking about and it's on
31 and 32 that's later on that's the
compensation so
if you look at the second sentence
starting line 24
this is a provision that basically says
if the attorney general
and and us the council for the claimants
can agree
well there's no need for the supreme
court to pick an administrator so really
what's trying to eliminate that need for
that step in the process if we can come
to an agreement with the attorney
general as to who might be the
administrator it seems an unnecessary
step
so you're just recommending an
efficiency step and and if you guys
agree to begin with you don't need to go
to the supreme court otherwise if you
don't agree you'd still go to the
supreme court correct
representative
yeah we just have to remember
that the supreme court is the one that
appoints the person
okay so if they go
with
everybody's in agreement with john doe
then
i would have to assume that
the supreme court would appoint john doe
so that that's rational if they just
forward one name with the information
that we've agreed on this please
put a stamp of approval on this then
it's still the supreme court nominee or
appointment
all right
is there any opposition to that anyone
on the committee
so so we'll go on i think we can do that
with the work group um
then we'll add we'll talk about number
four
adds false imprisonment as an
aggravating factor do you want to speak
to that
i'll speak to that one uh because this
is following my common law theme that i
started with the first two points
so this is uh
going back to the core issue of
including
all uh survivors we've you know we've at
least for now
let go of the fact that
false imprisonment would be a separate
claim standalone claim for this process
however
the attorney general has included
the idea of unlawful confinement being
an aggregating factor that the
administrator could could look at in
determining a value of a claim
so we've added false imprisonment which
is
really the common law
term for uh you know what i think the
attorney general is getting at with
unlawful confinement
there is a definition for unlawful
confinement earlier in the definition
section
it's um you know it's
i i would you know i would say a little
more complex than it needs to be and it
you know it throws up a lot of uh
potential defenses that the state might
raise
um
now when when we incorporate faults
imprisonment that's not to say the state
is defenseless there's that common law
there are justifications for
um you know for a false imprisonment
case so the state will have defenses but
again this this goes to my theme of um
let's stick to the common law
so uh help help the non-lawyers here um
we've gotten a little used to hearing
the term um solitary confinement uh to
what extent are these the same terms
just said differently or are they
different theories
well solitary confinement is uh
something that might occur at ydc
somebody might be placed in solitary
confinement it's not a cause of action
though it's not a cause of action at law
at common law uh to bring a claim for
solitary confinement you'd bring a claim
for uh false imprisonment which is
you know to to to cut to the chase you
know an unjustified imprisonment
with you know um and and i think you
know the the
the common law will provide the same
type of defenses this is the same type
of you know
justification defenses that the
statement might wish to raise
uh as a as they've included in their
definition of unlawful confinement
uh we'll do representative weiler and
then representative walls
my feeling is that
the original sentence to the ydc
could be interpreted as false
imprisonment and it's like appeal court
going back over why we are sent to ydc
and we have to relitigate that whole
thing over again i think it really opens
the door and broadens everything and
makes it more expensive and more
difficult
i'm not in favor of that
representative walls
i just want to say i've toured ydc a few
times and in addition to locking people
in the room
they have a chair there that they will
strap you to
and i
you know they claim they've used it only
when somebody's out of control but i
have no analogy when they use it i just
want to keep in mind that there's
multiple ways of confining people here
that may or may not have been used
appropriately and i just want to do
whatever definition we've got that
encompasses not only locking somebody in
their room but strapping somebody down
as they have apparently done there
um so my my general concern uh is just
scope creep on all of this and and so uh
it wasn't included originally uh mr
attorney general would you tell us your
thoughts on adding this
yes thank you mr chair i
i understand what plaintiff's counsel is
going for here
i don't think i would recommend adding
this as an aggregating factor because
as representative walt said it i don't
mean to interpret her comments as
agreeing with what i'm saying but as she
said there's a lot of different ways you
could confine someone that might be
some might view as false imprisonment
for for instance the use of restraints
at
at ydc
my impression is that's not what this
bill is is going for you know this bill
is not meant to sort of uh
retroactively evaluate the practices at
ydc
i
i struggle to come up with a
hypothetical where
something other than unlawful
confinement or solitary confinement
would make sense as an aggregating
factor for physical or
sexual abuse um i suppose if
if one were
i mean
given that these are individuals who are
already incarcerated i perhaps you would
have one hypothetical where
someone was in a locked room while they
were being abused and someone else was
was perhaps
not i so
it it strikes me as more of a risk for
scope creep than it would be
a benefit in in covering claims that
wouldn't otherwise be covered but
i know i'm not supposed to ask questions
because i'm not a member of the
committee but i would be curious as to
whether plaintiff's council had a
hypothetical where false imprisonment
might be a
an aggregating factor mr dean let's make
it a debate society do you want to
respond sorry that was just a curious
impressive curiosity
uh well i i i i don't have a particular
particular hypothetical in mind
but it's
you know obviously i don't it's not the
intent
of this change and this is only to
aggregating factors it's not to
adding a new claim
so it's not intent to relitigate the
reason why the claimant is in ydc to
begin with uh it's just um you know to
the extent they had some freedom
um to be in a general population and
then they are unjustifiedly
removed from that and put into a
solitary confinement for weeks or months
at a time
you know i that could fit a
a common law claim i i believe um
and so we're we're just trying to you
know get what we can uh and we
understand that we're not going to get
a standalone claim here for uh for false
imprisonment or solitary confinement or
any of those but um you know as an
aggregating factor
we thought that was fair game
all right i think i think we're ready
for
oh representative rogers please
and and do wave your hand at me because
there's
the
blocked a little bit okay no i just
think that um
adding the it's an aggregating factor
they're talking about it's not the um
single claim and we've heard
a number of instances on the claims that
have already been
brought to court of
elongated time in solitary confinement
and we keep in mind this does go to a
mediator this does go to someone that's
going to make a judgment on it i think
it's important to have in there because
we've seen time after time of example of
the solitary refinement being in my mind
at least abused
as a practice so i would like to see us
include it
thank you
thank you for that let me let me ask you
all a question um are we going to have a
specific conversation on solitary
confinement or is this as close as we
get to it
this is as close as we get and the
changes that we've put in this version
yes
okay so um i i think i'd like to conduct
a straw vote unless there any other
comments um
on item four
a vote in favor to raise your hand
is an agreement to add false improve
imprisonment as a aggravating factor
the second question will be opposed to
adding it
and i'm going to be voting as opposed to
adding it just in case anyone's curious
but so at this point
please raise your hand if you are in
favor of adding
false imprisonment as an aggravating
factor mr clerk would you
one help three four five
five in favor
all right uh those opposed to adding
raise your hand
one two three
four five six seven eight
again
so so we have an eight to five vote
um
all right so
bullet six
do you
do
you want to start bullet six
what wait a second
yeah there is no five so there's
actually only ten issues we have
nine issues right
there you go now you know the source of
the problem
so we we did take one off the list just
to make your life easier mr chairman um
expectation said yeah yeah thank you
all right so now we go to page
three lines 28 to 32. and again here
so
last time
at the last hearing
dave
react gave a brief reaction to the
notion
of having the administrator
be the same person who helps with the
guidelines
actually end up being the adjudicator of
claims
and we believe that having someone who
um
having someone involved
in the
discussion to mediate the discussion
between the attorney general
and the uh and us frankly
would be helpful if if we thought it was
needed i think that helps both the state
and us to make sure that you know to the
extent we think negotiations need some
help from a mediator uh you know this is
somebody who could be brought into the
process
to to help facilitate discussions
it's it's really just a way of hoping to
try to move this process forward more
efficiently
and you know it would be someone who is
not
going to make a decision it's someone
who's simply going to offer their
opinion
um to to to try to move the process
forward
okay so i'm i'm i'm reading 28 through
um line 31
on page
three and and that first sentence of
your red line
is is saying
as i as i read this that uh what you're
trying to do is get the administrator
in the loop before
the um i keep calling in a matrix the
the the claims form is built that you
want the administrator in before that's
finalized
instead of after it's been finalized
that's the key thing you're going for in
this sentence per sentence
except for the fact that you know this
is intended to ra address any concerns
if that person
would later be appointed to be the
full-time administrator or the permanent
administrator in other words
we think you know we had talked about
having the administrator
involved in the process of developing
the guidelines and we would rather say
here okay well it doesn't have to be the
administrator it can simply be some
other person who would be helpful and
then
the administrator himself would be later
determined
under this bill
so
so let me
nitpick at the word or the attorney
general or counsel for claimants
should that be an end
no because i'm presuming that either
party either side believes that it would
be helpful to have a mediator involved
in the process to move things forward
do you want to speak represent
[Music]
weiler
it seems like it's the same person
so okay you didn't agree with with my
ruling over here you're going over here
and it's a different situation now i'm
the mediator before i was the
administrator now i'm the mediator it's
the same person why would they change
their mind over what they've just done
you can respond if you'd like to yeah
representative while we're um
we're trying to
put someone in place to help the process
establish the guidelines those
guidelines will need to be
established before an administrator is
picked
right and so
that that's going to be a process where
we see things may
may run into trouble so here we're
asking that simply up to the point of
determining the guidelines a mediator
could be brought into the process
so
it feels to me like there's an element
of potential form shopping uh that's
built into the ore part of that and
um
it it it's it seems to me that the
attorney general's office
is responsible for
coming up with an acceptable set of
guidelines and that
negotiation and discussion and
accommodation is part of that process i
i i don't know that i'd want it so
easily bounced out of the ag's role into
an undetermined mediator's role and so
i i'll just ask you mr attorney general
what what your thoughts are on just
particularly the first sentence there
i
i think my thoughts are that
the a mediator could prove useful in
that process at some point but i don't
it doesn't strike me that it's necessary
to have to give either party the ability
to kind of unilaterally bring the
mediator
in i think there should be
there's there should be a discussion
first and and perhaps a mediator if each
so each party feels like that would be
helpful um
so do we just fix that with changing or
to and
that's how i would change it i i do i
know at least my understanding is
there's going to be another item further
down on the list that may also impact
this item so i i
that's i would but yes for now i would
change or to and i think that would make
more sense than having one party right
off the bat being able to
bring in an administ uh a mediator
representative yes uh thank you mr
chairman um it's my understanding and in
fact uh
janet is actually typing up the the for
the three three things that we had uh
discussed in caucus but um i i agree
with the
with the idea that it would that the
administrator
who was going to be sort of the final
adjudicator if you will
shouldn't be establishing the guidelines
but as as was
discussed earlier
i i i it seems to me
that while the while the attorney
general ought to get input from the
claimants on what the guidelines should
say
the final determination on determining
the guidelines should be the attorney
general's to make he should make the
final determination of what the
guidelines are
so so if we were to pursue that line of
thought
we would just simply not accept
the sentence starting at 28 on page two
starting upon the request of the
attorney general or counsel for
claimants the chief justice of the
supreme court shall appoint an
individual with qualifications to an
administrator to mediate the development
of the claims process and guidelines for
valuing claims
i think your recommendation would be
just to strike that
right and which it seems to me that
that's that's sort of you know creating
the possibility of an adjudicator to
decide what's going to later be
adjudicated
i don't see any reason to have that in
there
okay
so uh the attorney general has suggested
this is tied into another topic we're
going to discuss so i could just defer a
straw vote on this until we complete
this conversation i think
you'll you'll and you'll let me know
when we completed that conversation
sure
just to be clear it's all the uh it's an
item that i understand you know that the
member of the committee was going to
bring forward but but yes i can
certainly let you know when i think
we've reached the item that makes sense
to
combine with this item
thank you so then the second part of the
the of that
item is uh line 31 starts the
compensation the individual show to be
determined by the chief justice supreme
court and paid from the fund we've
already talked about how we're going to
write this on a so the part-time salary
could be determined
is so we're done with that
[Music]
so
i
i think we might be ready
for
a straw vote on line six but i'll i'll
hold off i i i don't think it's faring
well in my view but um so let's go on to
line seven do you want to talk to line
seven
okay um so this um this actually is more
of a restating of a position and
in a comments that dave has made
on a number of occasions and this is
on page four line
seven to ten and so
what we have offered here is language
that would set the
the caps
on settlements at the current standards
approved under new hampshire law and
that's 475
000 per
incident and then
it ties the second one ties to rsa
1435 b which is the aggregate cap
on settlements and
the reason for this is is generally that
you know we believe the process that's
going to capture the most
um
the most uh victims who are going to go
through it will give them a fair
opportunity to give recover what they've
already
are entitled to under law if they can
prove their case and so we see no reason
why there would be any need for a cap at
the 1.5 million dollars and you know to
the extent
you know there's concerns about uh
amounts that you know are going to be
settled you know compromises that need
to be made
uh those types of compromises will be
made
in the
claims
guidelines process as well as the
adjudication of claims so
the notion that this 1.5 million dollars
is appropriate here
i don't believe
is necessary and you know we think that
this process should have the same caps
that the victims would have if they
pursued their claims in in a court
that's right
i don't i don't remember the details of
that
475 000 being written into the statute
but as i as i recall generally
that 475 000 was meant to apply
in a different scenario in a scenario
that doesn't really
match
the analogy of this civil procedure um
do you know what i'm talking about
maybe miss mr attorney general could you
could you refresh my memory on where
that 475 comes from and your position on
whether or not it's pertinent
sure thank you mr chairman so the the
475 000 number is what i
kind of think of it and refer to as the
sovereign immunity cap for many civil
claims um
the state generally has sovereign
immunity that protects it from from
civil claims against the state but there
are exceptions and one of the general
exceptions is that the state
allows recovery of up to four hundred
and seventy five thousand dollars per
per incident um that's that's the the uh
the sovereign immunity cap
so i i i think
it's not the 475 000 cap is not meant to
be a a settlement cap it's meant to
to define sort of the upper limit of the
ability to recover for each incident uh
for which someone might bring a claim
against the state
the
the limit in 1435 b
is the is a settlement a cap there is a
cap on the attorney general's settlement
authority uh when the attorney general
is looking to settle cases and that is a
number that's equal to one quarter of
one percent of the previous fiscal
year's general fund revenues
i i think as i said last time you know i
think using that
that cap
and as an argument for why this cap
should be be the same
doesn't quite fit because
the for the cap in 1435 b
is is a general cap on any potential
claim against the state that the
attorney general might
settle and that's it's roughly 4.6
million dollars that cap
doesn't account for
what the specific claims might be or
what
how how valuable they might be
in this case we developed the number of
1.5 million dollars because we are
looking at a at a fairly unique category
of claims and as we've mentioned in the
past you know we we did the verdict
research we did the settlement research
we've seen what's been paid in other
cases involving these types of claims
and that's how we came up with 1.5
million dollars
the 4.6 million
dollar cap again is that's just a
general overall cap so you could imagine
particular claims that might be brought
against the state that the attorney
general might want to settle for 3.5 4
million dollars but those would be very
specific facts very very egregious and
you do
research on those types of claims in
this case we i think we've we've done
the research and 1.5 million is the
number we've we've arrived at so i
apologize that was a long answer to your
question no it's an excellent answer i i
i just jumped ahead to
looking at the 150
is is that
is that hundred and fifty thousand meant
to be the cap for physical abuse only
yes
and and how you remind remind me maybe
uh how did you come up with 150 so
within the verdict and settlement
research we did with there were cases
that involved physic physical abuse
claims um as as stand-alone claims it's
admittedly we have less of a sample size
for those but
i don't have the chart with me i didn't
bring it but the average that we
identified there was from about 65 000
to 75 000 per
claimant and so
while while i i would i think this 150
cap is fairly classified as a bit of a
bit rougher of an estimate than our 1.5
million estimate that's how we got that
150 000
number i think it's a
it's a pretty solid number i mean there
may be some room to to quibble with it
but with the numbers we've seen i think
that that cat makes sense for physical
abuse only claims
so i i i don't want to put words in your
mouth but i what i think i i hear you
say is that you
your preference would be to
maintain the language we had coming into
today yes that would be my
recommendation representing walls
thank you mr chairman um i i want to go
back to what i was talking about the at
the end of our last hearing and that is
the purpose of this is to try and keep
these cases out of the courts
and the caps that we're talking about
imposing here to me are a disincentive
to use this process
because the plaintiffs would be able to
recover
potentially substantially more money
outside of this process
if we leave the caps here where if we
take the caps and raise them to where
the plaintiffs have
then it seems to me like more people
might be inclined to use this process
thereby saving the state money from not
having to hire a lawyer to litigate
these cases
so
um
hang on i kind of had this worked out my
head let me figure this out where i was
going um
we're trying to set up a system that the
plaintiffs want to buy into
and it seems to me by putting the caps
in
some of the plaintiffs are not going to
want to buy in
and that is contrary to this purpose
they're not if they can recover more by
going to civil litigation
then it doesn't save the state any money
to have the caps on now because they're
just going to then
go to civil litigation if they if the
caps are too low for for their case or
if they think they're too low for their
case
and it's going to cost the state more
money because they got to hire a lawyer
so it seems to me
short-sighted to put these caps on
so long as there is the ability to
recover under civil litigation so you
could have a plaintiff choose not to use
this process
file a civil suit end up settling it
without the caps but even perhaps using
the same matrix that's going to be done
in this system but they would be exempt
from the caps because they went into the
courts instead of into this mediation
system
so i'm wondering
what's the point of the cap
if there's an alternative that's just
going to cost the state more but give
the plaintiffs the same ability to
recover higher than the caps that we're
currently imposing
so represent walls i i i agree with your
primary premise which is that if these
caps are too low
we will have destroyed the entire
purpose of this legislation
and and and what it seems to me is that
there's a balancing act of interests
where we want to entice enough people to
come into this um process
because of the simplicity of it the
anonymity of it the speed of it the
you know the the trust that gets
developed in the administrator's uh
judgments
that
that ultimately we we have asked so far
the attorney general to weigh
the amounts the caps
so that
the enticements are there but that we
also balance the interests of the
taxpayers as well and and
this this has been the attorney
general's i think and his in his staff's
best
efforts to establish
a fair and reasonable cap
in order for this whole
settlement fund to work in the first
place and and and i i i just did put
words in your mouth but do you have any
comments on that
yes thank you mr chair i
i would echo a lot of what you said in
just in response to representative waltz
i would say you know i
i
from the beginning i think the way we
and by we i mean the department of
justice have looked at this is that this
is an attempt to
you know provide an alternative option
that that
again is is a easier smoother gentler
more victim-friendly uh trauma-informed
process than litigation
and that also provides provides fair
compensation
that said i think we've always
acknowledged that this this would
potentially for some claimants provide
less compensation that they might be
able to
receive if they if they went all the way
through
um
their their case so if they went all the
way through discovery and they they got
through
pre-trial motions they got through
dispositive motions they had a trial
took the stand
got a jury verdict they could get a jury
verdict for more money that takes a long
time
it's
it's not a very victim-friendly
trauma-informed process you know
litigation is a contact sport and and i
think for a lot of these victims that
that process would not be appealing if
we went through that process as a
department of justice we'd be obligated
to defend these cases and and we will
and we would defend these cases and we'd
we defend them vigorously so i think
you know this has meant
this is as i think i've said from our
perspective it's all about balance
you know we we want to provide an
alternative option
we want that option to be much smoother
gentler more victim-friendly trauma
informed than the traditional litigation
process but with that i think has to
come
a fair valuation of these claims and the
only way
in the context of a settlement process
and the best way i can think of to do
that is to look at the other you know
look at what other
numbers have looked like in
in settlements of similar claims and
that's what we've tried to do but but
all that said i i acknowledge that there
may be claimants who this isn't enough
money and they think they can get more
by by litigating and it's worth it to
them to go through the more difficult
litigation process to get that higher
amount they have every right to do that
and while i say we defend them
vigorously we'd certainly do it
respectfully but we would we would
fulfill our obligations to to go through
that process
so
i think representative rogers had her
hand up first
i understand the attorney general's
view on this however taking it from a
victim's viewpoint many of these victims
have waited a number of years so time is
not necessarily
something that they're not used to
having to wait
it's been going on for
close to 50 years down
and we could have someone come back
that's waited a number of years for it
so i don't think the time argument is
necessarily one that all of them are
going to look at the other thing is
taking an average while it's a way to do
it
i don't think is a fair way in something
like this each claim is very different
each claim is very personal to the
claimant
and
they've gone through this they have the
pain they have the suffering they know
what happened
i think a number of them will want to go
to court if there's a limit i don't know
if it's something that we can just
take out a cap altogether
as a compromise between the two
positions but i think that um setting an
arbitrary number of 150
um
at this point is just not
where we should go i think that we need
to
um
let the claimants know that we're open
to whatever's going on there's some and
i don't think the majority of them are
going to be on the high end of this
necessarily but i think that we need to
let the
victims know that there's a possibility
that there is going to be more and that
they don't necessarily have to go to
court that they can go through this
process that will be better um yes i
know the state will vigorously defend
something but
um that's money in time that that they
necessarily don't want to spend either
um and would rather go through the claim
this this process so i would just argue
that we should look to not limit it to
the one five and um
look at the either the plaintiff's
alternative or a compromise of not even
mentioning a cap
thank you representative walsh do you
still have a comment
just real quick and that is
you know the attorney general set up the
scenario where somebody would file suit
and they would have to go to trial we
know that the vast majority of cases
that are filed do not go to trial they
are settled and what i see happening
is
somebody files suit and they end up
settling perhaps consistent with the
grid that's out there because it's going
to be cheaper for the attorney general
to settle and not have to pay outside
counsel or one of his own people
then it is
to go through the whole trial and i
think that's a more likely scenario but
i think if you've got these caps in
place it's just a motivation to go
around this system and to file suit as
opposed to if you raise the caps or you
don't have caps in place
and let it be the
immunity limits then i think that it's
more likely that somebody's going to use
this system which i think in the end is
beneficial to the state as well as the
plaintiffs
uh thank you representative lynn yeah i
i with
all due respect to representative walls
uh and representative rogers i really
think that i i feel strongly that
the caps should stay in place and that
they are set at an appropriate level and
i think one of the things that the
attorney general said i think is really
important to understand
is this and this is this has always been
really my concern and i think maybe some
other members of the committee's concern
from the beginning about this
i i applaud the attorney general for
having set up this this
you know procedure and suggested it to
us and for us considering it and i think
we should obviously go forward with it
but
this as the attorney general said is a
very
plaintiffs friendly system
if you were if if you were concerned
about determining the
absolute truth of whether somebody was
was sexually abused or physically abused
um you would not go through this process
you would want and i sort of i'm
speaking for the uh from the perspective
of the attorney general or a defendant
in the case you would want to have a
fully litigated fully discovered case
because
candidly there is a i have no doubt
that many of the people who are
claimants were actually abused and
should be compensated
but
this system
is plaintiffs friendly enough
that there is i i would submit
a significantly greater risk
that someone
who has not been abused
but knows that
the he can claim something or she can
claim something that happened a long
time ago
where there are no records or very much
incomplete records there's nobody
perhaps the alleged uh assailant is dead
or gone can't be located and it's very
easy
to claim i was abused
and and receive compensation and so
i think that is a real concern
but i think the attorney general has
concluded and i agree with his
assessment that because there are
a significant number of people who
really have been abused
and should be compensated it's
appropriate to have this very relaxed
plaintiffs friendly system
to do that but what it seems to me that
the cost that comes with that or the
trade-off for that is there have got to
be appropriate caps
and i think that these are very
appropriate gaps and although i you know
i i think the world of davis and anzo i
don't know current council really very
well at all but i think the world of
david sinanzo i've known him for years
he's an excellent attorney and the
plaintiffs are in great hands by being
represented by him but
i have to say candidly i would be very
surprised
if there are a significant number of
cases assuming we passed this
legislation i would be very surprised if
there are significant number of cases
that aren't adjudicated through this
process as opposed to litigation there
may be some there may be some that are
really bad where there's a really strong
case and people will go to uh you know
we'll just we'll opt to go to court but
that will be the exception rather than
the rule
uh thank you so i i think i'm ready to
call a straw vote uh representative
mooney did you have something you wanted
to add first i did just have a brief
question mr chairman for the attorney
general if that would be in order
just in terms of some background
through the years have any victims filed
suit and gone through the process you
described with discovery in a jury trial
in a settlement and a judgment
you mean potential victims
at ydc have they gone through the entire
process and gotten a jury verdict
not that i'm aware of i'm aware of one
i'm aware of off the top of my head one
and i don't have the details but one
case
regarding someone who was incarcerated
so not at ydc where they went through an
entire you know they fully litigated
their case they got to a jury verdict
this was a physical abuse only claim and
the verdict was for 80 000 so that's
just a just an example but i that's the
only one that i can speak to that's not
to say there aren't others but it's rare
that someone would fully that a case
like this would be fully litigated
thank you that's helpful thank you mr
chairman
you're welcome so
at this point
i think we'll do a straw vote on item
seven
uh establishes the current statutory
caps on recoveries
uh
if when i
first ask i'll ask if you support the
language proposed uh i'll i'll i'll be
voting for the second which is to vote
opposed to establishing the statutory
caps as as proposed by the plaintiffs so
um
so on the first vote
if you are in favor of the plaintiffs
changes to the
the statutory caps please raise your
hand
if you're opposed to the changes please
raise your hand
so the vote is eight to five for the uh
working committee um
all right so let's let's do a time check
um
we're we're gonna we've got a hard break
at 5 30 uh and we're also wanting um
miss ripple do you can you give us a
status on whether or not uh ols will
have
103. yep we have the amendment now
okay so um i'm probably going to end
this um
about 5 20 so that division 3 has 10
minutes to consider the amendment that
ols has so
i i i tell you that so that you can pace
yourself and
efficiently use your time
um and if and if we have to go over
because we're just not done we've
already said we're going to re recess
today anyways until
thursday at 2 p.m
so item 8
so item 8 is another one for me it's on
line 31 on page 4.
and
this is pretty straightforward in what
it provides
it basically
the sentence itself says
no claim shall be filed by an executive
administrative a deceased former ydc
resident then presumably that's to make
sure that
claims by
the family
uh and the heirs
of a a victim
don't have a right to go through this
process
currently they would have that right
to pursue action in in a court of law
and then
what
what we added was except by the
surviving spouse of the resident
uh and frankly
um i think that we added this back in
for the fundamental reason that
when you have somebody who has
been married to a survivor presumably
that person has lived with the
consequences of the abuse
that
was
imposed on the survivor
during their lifetime
and in this context i don't know how
this bill
in this legislature should tell that
spouse that surviving spouse that she's
not worthy to go through this process
and force it to go to a court of law
so so thank you just to speed this along
a little bit you know my my thought on
that is that
um
the surviving spouse um when when their
spouse dies they die with the and the
pain goes with them they the the
surviving spouse
was not the
direct recipient of the of the pain and
anguish and the suffering
it was secondary and so
so the pain largely dies with the with
the um
the one that was incarcerated and abused
the other is that
with with that individual dies the
direct testimony and observation and so
everything gets to become second hand
and hearsay
i i just think that just adds too much
complexity and i i wouldn't be in favor
of adding the surviving spouse i i know
it's tragic to lose a spouse but i i
don't know that this is the remedy for
that so uh or is there any other
commentary from anyone on that uh
representative walner
i i just wondered what would happen if
a claimant had started the process
and died before the process was complete
and they
were they were
left a spouse and family so how would
that be handled
um
i would say based upon the way it's
written now
it's measured at the time the claim is
filed so i would the attorney general
might have a different opinion but i
would assume that that claim could
continue
um but i do
yeah
thank you
so so representative weiler go ahead
i see room for problems here
a person who's not otherwise attractive
who's got an ongoing case
trying to get some woman to marry him
hey
i've got stage four cancer you marry me
you're in for payoff at some point
whether i get this money or not
i'm just saying
it's not always an honest thing we're
not dealing with honest people thank you
so i i think representative waller just
erased a really good question that i
hadn't thought of what what what happens
to the status of the claim
if the person filing the claim dies
before the administrator finishes the
paperwork
i think the the way i've sort of
envisioned it in the way i would read
the statute is that once the claim is
filed
it could
the claim's been filed so if someone
passes away before it's been fully
adjudicated that doesn't destroy the
claim i mean i think it may affect
where the ultimate decision comes out
because it might affect
what's available to
to both the administrator and and
perhaps the deceased counsel and the ag
when it comes to verifying and getting
the facts so it could affect the
ultimate value
but but from my perspective i think the
cutoff is is at the claim filing and i
think that gets to the
what i see is the primary concern which
is that without
the victim
having filed the claim you don't have a
direct statement from the victim and
these claims are hard enough to to sort
through and verify given how old they
are without having that direct statement
from the victim makes it difficult but
that same concern isn't there if a claim
has been filed by the victim and they
only pass away after the claim has been
filed so my next question then for you
is uh do you think the language in the
bill is clear on the status of the claim
should the
claimant die in the process
it probably isn't clear enough so if
um i mean i'll
to be honest i hadn't thought about that
coming in today but it sounds like there
may be room for clarification which we'd
be happy to work on some language for if
it is the the the committee's
desire that that actually be the case
that's how i've read the language
assuming the committee is in agreement
with that we i can certainly work on
some language with kevin to to clarify
that so so mr dean and mr hayden if if
we were um to uh clarify the language
as we've discussed here um would you
would that meet your
your interests
or or are you wanting to be able to will
a claim to somebody
after the
when there's no longer a time for them
to file their own claim
uh so those changes would be helpful and
um we would agree we certainly think
they go in the right direction and if
particularly for clarification however
you know
we're not asking for the complete
ability to will a claim we're talking
about a surviving spouse who may
you know in legal terms inherited by a
will or under the
the
laws of intestacy in the state of new
hampshire
but you would limit that to only um
remuneration that would fall
after the claim had already been filed
by the living
victim right i i agree with that in
concept yes
okay so i don't see any disagreement
it's just words that need to be written
to clarify so i i think we'll forego a
straw vote on that unless there's any
opposition to just assuming
all right
let's go to
item 9
reminds a victim of his or her rights at
an earlier stage in the process
so
item 9 is page seven lines four to six
um and this is this is i think
an attempt
to try to
address the practicalities of a process
and you know i believe this bill
contemplates that you know claimants may
get a final offer from
the attorney general's
designee and not respond for one reason
or another
and i understand the practical side of
that
of that
type of deemed acceptance if you will
we put language in there that really is
duplicated below that says
you know effectively the administrator
can assume
that they accept it but it just makes it
needs to be clear that somewhere in the
process when they were notified of the
award they were had fair notice of what
their
rights were under this process and
this is exactly the same language set
forth
below
uh where is it
it's at line 23 or so
where is it
no it's not that that's not where it is
but it's definitely
as i recall a conversation from this one
last week um
plaintiff's
counsel
accepted the idea that uh
documenting it in writing
may may not
may be going too far that maybe a verbal
kind of communication would be
sufficient this this this writes and
that it be put in writing
um and i'm just curious if if
if you all shifted on that in the last
few days or my memory's bad
really haven't except we we've added to
the process you know this this presumes
i i would think uh
a a claimant who is not represented by
council you know you could certainly
expect
that council
if they were involved in the discussion
would make sure that there was a proper
response to the settlement claims
offered this is for claimants who don't
retain counsel
and you know to the extent there's a
notice that says
this is the final offer
you know we do think it's it's
not necessary in the context
of a
of someone who's represented but to the
extent they're not represented we see no
harm in requiring notice uh at the time
when the ag's
given the final
determination of what they're willing to
settle on
okay i'll i'll ask it this way i'm
because i'm having trouble uh reading
the whole paragraph and contextualizing
what you're saying with the words that
are on the document so i'm i'm i'm going
to ask you if you think the writing is
currently already clear that you've
redlined
to to make
make this part of the
the law
when
the victim does not have counsel
and only then is that your is that
correct that you you you don't
necessarily want this in writing
for those that have no counsel
so this revision assumes that the
provision later on that says the
administrator will provide this
information
at the time
before
um
then what i'm saying here is that this
idea should this notice should be given
to
the uh
to the
claimant at the time the ag provides
their information so if if the
legislature believes this notice is
important i think it should be
provided before
a claimant in effect you know does
nothing and waives their rights to
further
pursue this claim either by withdrawing
it or
or
asking the administrator to decide the
claim
so
representative weiler
you don't spell it out but you mentioned
that it's for those that have no counsel
that's right
perhaps that language should be included
so so um mr a.g
this does this does
does this red line from four to
six on page seven represent a material
difference in what you view how you
viewed the process or what you think is
acceptable
if you if you don't have an answer on
the spot please just say so
yeah so
i mean so right before this paragraph at
the bottom of page six or i'm if i'm
looking at the same version you all are
but at right before paragraph h
so it's g
i mean it
the current draft does say within 30
days of receiving the investigation
report the ag must designate or indicate
to the claimant and the administrator
its updated position
regarding the claim
and the administrator will advise the
claimant regarding their options at that
point
um so
so does that imply that this additional
language is redundant
it's
redundant i i think
i understand the concept i think the
concept makes sense the one concern i
have with putting it here not to get too
nitpicky is that
this confuses it a little bit i mean
we're putting a deadline i think on the
claimant to elect an option
so think they've already been provided
this notice i don't know how many times
i need to be provided the notice but
so it strikes me as unnecessary but i
also don't feel that strongly about it
that that's
i think it would be fine
if but there may be a better way to do
it that i just can't come up with off
the top if it's if it's redundant and
possibly conflicts
or confuses
then we shouldn't do it it's my view
yeah i
i would suggest that maybe we work on
some language to try to accomplish this
without having it result in any
confusion sort of further down the
the
path during the process because what i
wouldn't want to have happen is
i think it makes sense that there needs
to be a deadline by which the
the claimant needs to indicate whether
they're agreeing with the aeg designee's
position or not
and if that deadline passes
i just want to avoid a situation which
there's then an argument about whether
they were ever provided notice of their
options or whether they were provided
notice of their options every single
time they had to be provided notice of
their options
and and result in the hang up so i i
think we can probably accomplish this
by tweaking this language slightly
okay so that that tweak will appear in
the working groups edits and we'll be
voting on it on thursday and if we can
we'll we'll try to get it to the
plaintiff's council as early as possible
if you slip them
a draft before ols
finishes it i i wouldn't have a problem
with that okay
do you have any
other comments on that
i don't and i and i think
i'm sure we can figure out some language
that works
all right good um so i think we're on
your item 10.
item 10
yes that's me
and and so this concerns
and this is at
page 8 of our red line line 6 to 12
and this concerns having some judicial
review of this process
so uh you know
we agree with the attorney general's
finality concerns
and and therefore in our markup we we
agree that there
doesn't need to be a pellet review
that said we we do believe there's there
is
a place for some limited judicial review
of this process this uh
alternative dispute resolution process
and um and and and we do believe that
our claimant should have should be
entitled to get a judgment a court
judgment
uh at the end of this process if they
believe that they need one
so um
we've cited to uh the
uh
rsa 542-8 which is the part of the
arbitration statute and
um
and achieving a
a confirmation and a judgment uh in a
court following an arbitration um
and i you know i believe the the
attorney general's version had had
previously referred to it as well
although um you know striking out this
uh this review provision and also the
appeal
so um
i think it's actually helpful if i just
read to you you know the what we're what
we're what we're asking the court to do
here which i think is is pretty narrow
uh and especially we've narrowed it
further in in our red line here
so uh
in an arbitration proceeding or in in
this proceeding the court will only
correct or modify the award for plain
mistake
or will vacate an award for fraud
corruption or misconduct by the parties
or by the arbitrators or on the ground
that the arbitrators have exceeded their
powers
now as i said we've uh the the one um
the one ground listed there uh plain
mistake is is the one that could be
read broadly and some courts have so
we've restricted it in our revision here
to only mathematical errors
in other words we're not asking a court
to second guess what the administrator
has done
we're just asking the court to ferret
out corruption fraud misconduct or
obvious mathematical errors
and we think that form of limited review
is is justified and appropriate
and and if a claimant wants to go and
get a judgment once they get a court to
review and get a judgment they should be
able to do that just as they would in an
arbitration proceeding
so you're you're um
you're making reference to corruption
and fraud and i don't i don't see those
words on the document so are those
embedded in the rsa you've referenced
yeah the rsa i just read to you 5428
provides the the narrow grounds that a
court will review an arbitrator's award
and and those narrow grounds we have
further narrowed in in our uh draft here
all right mr mr attorney general do you
have a comment for us
yeah i mean i again i i understand that
the intent of this i would have a
concern with it i
i'm not as concerned with the the
mistake piece and i think that could be
achieved perhaps by giving the
opportunity to petition the
administrator to do a take a second look
if there's a thought that there might be
a mistake but
the the statute is just it's a little
bit broader than that it gets into fraud
corruption misconduct but also on the
ground that an arbitrator has exceeded
their powers i just think that opens
opens up a number of potential arguments
here
and and really would give potentially
the ability to argue to the court that
the administrator has not
applied the guidelines correctly and
thus has exceeded their powers
and thus it i think potentially provides
just another
another
level of review for this in court which
i think
the whole purpose of this is to avoid
and
even if you file something in court just
to
just to try to correct a mistake that
requires you know the attorney general
to look at it and potentially file
something in response
i i i think it's i think it's
unnecessary i think it it kind of goes
against the purpose of this process i
understand the intent behind it but i
think if there's a concern for
just plain mistakes or mathematical
errors i think that's better achieved by
giving an opportunity to petition the
administrator to take a second look than
to
then to open this up to
to court which is what we tried to avoid
may i address yes
so uh
as far as exceeding powers i you know i
think we could probably concede on that
and make a further revision uh if that
was a deal breaker
um
and and i just want to also highlight
you know and i think david visananzo has
had said this repeatedly that we're
dealing with trust with these plaintiffs
uh and and i think having this
this limited very narrow form of
judicial review at the end of the
process
to make sure it's on the up and up and
everything's been done right and and if
they think it's necessary they can get a
court order and a judgment at the end of
this process i you know i think they
should be entitled to do that
so representative weiler had his hand up
first and then represented umber
so this is a unique process we're hoping
it works if it doesn't we change it but
in the meantime the whole purpose was to
avoid court
to avoid costs in courts if hundreds of
cases go to the court for review they're
going to come back to us and say you
didn't give us enough money because it's
taken a lot of judiciary time
to review these hundreds of cases so
this is a unique process i'd rather let
it see how it runs if it's successful if
we seem to settle most of this stuff
without in a short period of time and
don't have to drag most of them into
court then we've been successful i don't
want to drag this into court so that's
that's i am opposed
represent umber
uh yes um
i don't think we can forget that the
administrator
is
appointed by
the um
supreme court
and so
he's already
the highest court official
and so
my you know so
we're going to have someone down at a
lower court level
review a decision that is made by
somebody
in the supreme court area so i just
i just think that uh it's um
it's totally
unnecessary and i do agree with the
attorney general if we want to add
something in there that says
you know nobody's perfect and uh and the
administrator might make a mistake
on
you know math or whatever
then
you know i have i have no problem with
that but
i think we all know
that the guidelines the
monetary awards are all going to be
out there for everybody to look at
and so you know somebody could
just
administrator said abc and equate it to
a million two
and if someone goes back and adds it up
and it actually is a million four then i
think the administrator could change
that without
getting some kind of judgment from
i assume the superior court
i would hate for that to have to go back
to the supreme court
um all right so i i i think we should
probably straw vote this um
the way the way i'd like to tee this up
is i'd like to
have the attorney general in the in the
working group uh take another look at
this idea that there's some sort of an
appeal process in here to where
the administrator could be flagged to to
take a second look at what they did just
to make sure that we're not making
mistakes that just get through the
system
and keeping it out of the courts
i i don't really have an opinion on it
but but for the straw vote i'd like to
phrase it so that if you raise your hand
you're in favor of the working group
coming back to this particular section
and looking for
a way to make sure that there is an
appeals process
adequate for
the mistake of the math mistakes that
could be made
so if you raise your hand yes
then that's what they'll do if you raise
your hand no we'll probably have a
little more discussion
so if you're in favor please raise your
hand
one two three four five six
if you raise your hand then you agree
with me
no
i'm sorry it's getting it's getting late
no if you raise your hand what you're
saying is you you want the attorney
general and the working group to take a
look at
this section of the bill because the
plaintiffs would like to have a judicial
review
basically an appeals process put in
there
and what the what the attorney general
has suggested is maybe there's a way to
have the administrator
come back and take a fresh look at the
decision and the math and all to
make a secondary confirmatory
decision
and and that we don't see that language
right now because he's going to work on
it yes sir without it going to court
yes my proposal what what what i'm
asking in the straw vote if they should
write this in a way in which we don't
take it back to the judiciary because as
representative ownberger pointed out
this is essentially an agent of the
supreme court this is this is
should be a pretty
capable competent individual so
an appeal process to a lower court
in some ways just doesn't seem to make
sense yes sir so one more question so i
assume the appeal process would be
limited to a review of how it was done
and and the mathematics of it right
right there
so i've not read uh 542 colonnade so so
what based on what i've heard here today
the other com elements that maybe should
be considered are things like fraud and
corruption
but as i'm thinking about it it makes no
sense if the administrator is the one
that acted fraudulently or corruptly
they can't really review themselves in
those situations anyways i mean a math
error anyone can make a math error
so i i see that as being reviewable
so so does that answer your question
so this so this i guess i i don't have a
problem with the way
we wrote the thing
with the with the amendment
that we're working with not that the
plaintiff's amendment
but i'm uncertain how to vote in that
case
i unders i understand your concern i
respect your vote um the the process i'm
trying to follow here uh representative
uh
is
is the plaintiffs it i think it's
important to the entire process
that
the plaintiffs council
doesn't necessarily agree with
everything the legislature is doing but
that we've been fair
and they've been heard and and this is
an area where it seems to me like maybe
there's an element they raise a good
point is there a way for us to deal with
it fairly so that they know that their
opinion has been respected that's that's
that's where i'm coming from and that's
why i'm going to vote yes
but i respect whatever vote you exercise
i very much appreciate the clarification
thank you all right
so um with that let's take the straw
vote on
asking the working group to come back
and take a look at a little supplemental
language that would and would create an
appeals process
back to the administrator for a second
review based on math errors and the like
is uh what's that representative
yeah
it's technically written written here
mathematical mistakes or miscalculations
and
you know i i think they can leverage the
language
so with that
if you agree
raise your hand please
if you're opposed you'll raise your hand
one two two okay
all right i hopefully you can work with
that
okay so with that
uh
we're pretty much done there were some
supplement
we're done because we're out of time is
the problem
the the um
we had
i know i know but oh is that 4 20 yes
oh my god
oh we got lots of time i don't know what
the pace we're going to do no no no no
no we just finished up the plaintiff's
piece of this and
we
thank you so much i have a bad eye so
when i looked that way my peripheral
vision was not good thank you sir
okay so
uh
in caucus we talked about
uh and and if you're looking for an
estimate how long this is going to take
this feels to me like it should just
take another 20 30 minutes at most okay
so
in caucus there was a discussion on foss
and the foss exemption i think we dealt
with that earlier so that one's done
right
then there was something about uh
whether or not
the language on caps and having uh the
cap the caps put on the judici on the
awards were reasonable and then there
was something about taking 25 percent
out from the potential contingency fee
do you want do you want to talk us
through that representative was that
your issue it was and if i may um and i
uh i should note that
attorney scolambrini and a
representative of the um
new hampshire association for justice
are are here
they raised this issue and i had a
discussion uh with both of them but for
but a pretty lengthy discussion with
attorney scolambrini um who raised the
issue and i think uh representative
emerick you had raised this issue last
time at our hearing that
having the having the two stage 25
percent 33 percent uh
cap on attorneys fees
uh could arguably encourage an attorney
uh to to want to go to uh
to to go through the the administrative
adjudication i mean the administrative
and having the administrator determine
the case as opposed to settling earlier
simply for the purpose of getting a
higher
attorney's fee i i should just note that
if it were able to be proved that an
attorney actually did that and that was
the only reason for doing it the
attorney would be subject to discipline
i have no no doubt about that but
proving that that happened was would be
very very difficult to do so anyway
uh what attorney scolombrini suggested
and i think it makes sense is to take
out
that the two-stage uh process so what i
have proposed here
um uh is uh in this is the second
uh
item down it's number 14
uh roman numeral 14 and it's it reads it
would change the existing bill to read
as follows
the administrator may approve
i want to call a out there okay so using
uh the umberger amendment
what page and what line item are you
wanting us to jump into yes i'm sorry
thank you
it is on
page line 27 8
line 27
uh
right yes line 27 so that uh which is
roman numeral 14
and so that paragraph would
be removed and substituted would be
the following
the administrator may approve all fees
and costs of the attorneys who represent
claimants and proceedings before the
administrator the administrator shall
not approve any request for an attorney
for an attorney uh fees
for attorney's fees or caught there's a
typo there but for attorney's fees or
costs which are not reasonable
the administrator shall not approve an
attorney's fee in excess of 33 and 30
percent of the amount of the award
all costs and attorneys fees paid to the
claimant's attorney shall be paid from
the amount awarded to the claimant it's
that sort of takes out there's only one
there's only there's only one cap on
fees it's 33 in the third percent
that doesn't mean the administrator has
to award that the administrator can
award a lower amount if that's the
reasonable amount but 33 and a third is
the cap
whether it the case resolves early
or at following a full adjudication and
i think it's ernie scombre's
point on this and i think it's well
taken is
very often the reason that a case will
resolve early
is the attorney for the claimant has put
in a lot of work
to put the case together and to convince
the attorney general that the case is
worth settling early um and the and the
the
the claimant and the attorney
representing the claimant shouldn't be
penalized if they've done that work so i
think that's if and that that would i
think i've accurately summarized what
attorney brainy would would say so so
let's go ahead and get you on record why
don't you come up and and use the
microphone here and introduce yourself
and just state what your position is
relative to what representative lynn
just said
mr chairman my name is anthony
scullenbriny i'm here on behalf of nhaj
the last name
i hope oh man if you thought this ananza
was bad uh s-c-u-l-i-m-b-r-e-n-e
is my last name i i work out of a small
firm it's me and a former prosecutor
leslie gill we run gill and skull and
briny in nashua
i've practiced in new hampshire for a
long time and i've done cases involving
kids that have been abused i've also
actually practiced the public defender
where i represented kids that were in
the process of being abused while being
held at ydc uh so i've had a different
perspective than
the other people that have testified in
front of you
representative lin accurately summarized
my position
and i think that the reason why this is
the better way to go
is because in looking at how
similar mass torts have been handled in
other jurisdictions specifically in
federal court there is uh a process by
which the plaintiff's council submits a
request for a fee
in a for example a class action and then
the judge evaluates the merits of the
fee and in doing that they've generated
case law in this point and one of the
things that the case law says over and
over again is that there is a value to
the plaintiffs and having an expeditious
resolution and i can think from my own
personal examples the number of cases
that i've had involving similar
situations to this that resolved
pre-suit are all of them
you know when i take a case like this it
represents a significant risk to me
personally i can tell you that cases
that we've had that are similar to cases
like these require an enormous amount of
expense on the front end on our part
we're putting our money that could
otherwise be
sent home to you know get a new car or
something else we're putting that money
on the table because it's a contingency
fee we won't get that money back unless
we collect for the injured party and so
that gives attorneys in this system a
real incentive to take meritorious cases
and that's not to say that all the cases
are meritorious so that all the
attorneys take meritorious cases but the
idea that you would
disincentivize working things up ahead
of time
and encourage people to go to this
hearings process sort of
cuts against the purpose of the bill the
purpose of the bill is to make a
victim-centered expeditious process to
resolve these claims and i think that
good attorneys and this is going to
sound corny but my experience in new
hampshire is that most of the attorneys
are good attorneys will recognize the
value to their clients to whom they have
an ethical obligation to resolve these
claims as soon as possible and so if you
create this unusual incentive to stretch
it out my fear is that that that
incentive could be abused or
that that incentive could be something
that becomes systemically disruptive to
the process
so thank you for that and and maybe
maybe you're not the right one to ask
this but i'll i'll ask anyways um
doesn't giving the administrator the
discretion
to approve attorneys fees up to 33 and a
third percent
that doesn't that also create a an odd
incentive for the administrator to
basically rubber stamp 33 and a third
for every case
you know i i think that that's something
that is really governed by the norms of
practice for civil plaintiff cases and
oftentimes that is the the number that's
set i know that there are places where
they vary for example in this state if
you're representing somebody under this
age of 18
the statute provides a cap of 25 and i
point out that that statute has been in
effect for a long time and it provides
less incentive for cases involving kids
to come forward which is in part why
this problem has taken so long to get
addressed so
i think that
the incentive issue
is something that we can deal with that
we've dealt with before but you know
there are cases that go against the norm
in civil practice and ask for higher
amounts on a contingency fee such as
medical malpractice cases in some places
slip and fall cases where they'll have a
variance from the norm of 33 and a third
percent but i think is that as the limit
is fundamentally fair and reasonable
because that's what's being done out in
the marketplace right now
so so
um i understand that but the part of
this that uh maybe you could help me
with is
early on in the process when the victim
shows up to talk to an attorney and they
start talking through the case and start
talking through the implications of of
how much money could be received i would
think early on the attorney would want
to uh point out what their contingency
fee would be if it's a variable
rate like this where we you know you
don't know until the end of it
how how would the attorney
give the
information
early enough so that the victim knows
what they're dealing with
you know this is an issue that's dealt
with all the time by lawyers that
represent plaintiffs in class actions
and i believe the way that it's normally
done is that you explain to them that
the cap is this much and you could get
up to that much as your fee but it's
like it's possible that the
administrator could ask for less and
that the statute controls the fee by
giving discretion to the administrator i
mean it's the same thing when you
represent somebody in a criminal case
you don't know what their sentence is
going to be you don't know whether the
jury is going to find them guilty or not
and we still deal with that uncertainty
all the time so i don't think it's
necessarily an unworkable system to have
it be left to the administrator because
it happens all the time in mass tort
cases in federal court every day
so mr attorney general you do you have
the language that's been proposed and
there's just one typo in there that
representative lynn pointed out but um
do you have any comment do you think
this is improves the bill that we have
or or not
yeah i mean i i would agree with
attorney scalimbrini and representative
lin regarding i think the point was well
taken regarding the incentives and we
had talked about that i think in a
previous hearing that
you know to have a potential higher
higher cap on attorney's fees if you
take
a claim through the resolution process
could potentially provide a
perverse incentive to to drag drag the
case out
i do think in reality you know attorney
an attorney is governed by their ethical
obligations and if it's better for their
client to settle earlier i i think the
vast majority of attorneys we wouldn't
have to worry that they'd just drag a
case out in order to get higher
attorneys fees but i think i think that
incentive point was well taken i also
agree that
um
that we certainly wouldn't want to
disincentivize
good work up front to avoid having to go
through a resolution process
i would also agree with attorney
scalimbrini on the concern that
um
that having a sort of that there would
be uncertainty with uh with a cap like
this i i think i agree it's not that
uncommon for
for
you know an attorney and a client in in
certain kinds of cases especially master
cases or other other types of cases to
have a negotiation regarding what the
attorney's contingency fee is going to
be and then get to the end of the case
and you still have to go
and and get get your
your award of attorney's fee or your
your attorney fee number confirmed by
the court in this case it'd be the
administrator and so
it's not that uncommon to have some
level of uncertainty there but i think
what the client will know when they
negotiate with their attorney is
they'll know that it's not going to be
any higher than what's in their
agreement
and
my sense is
is that
if this number is in the bill
any
client
who's going to go through this prior any
claimant is going to go through this
process they'll they'll probably have
that discussion with their attorney they
will know that the that the number is
the highest potential number is going to
be 33 and a third percent so all that to
say that was another long answer but
i i generally think this is an
improvement and i and i am in general
agreement with attorneys gallon bruni's
comments
thank you are there any other comments
from the committee members
all right so i'm i'm not sensing any
opposition to this so without anyone
stopping me i'm just gonna ask the
working group to adopt this language as
replacement language and
you know just do it
substantially in the same way fix a typo
or two but
i think we're we're okay with this
direction anyone would disagree
nope
all right so um
so thank you we're getting ready to talk
about right to know is that is that your
topic or do you want to go back to the
cheap seats my goal is to make this as
easy and as quick as possible for you
guys so mr chair for the record my name
is marissa chase
m-a-r-i-s-s-a-c-h-a-s-e i'm the
executive director for the new hampshire
association for justice
i bring tony to as many legislative
hearings as i can because he's sustained
he succinct distinct and has a lot of
real-world professional and personal
experience across all areas of criminal
and civil law so you know certainly if
there are others in the room that are
more um you know focused on the right to
know issues would gladly
you know switch places with them but i
also trust tony's legal brain to provide
any insight that might be helpful on
this piece or any other piece of the
bill
thank you
do we have any language on the
substitute for right i do and this would
be uh in
this would be on page
eight uh page nine i'm sorry
in roman numeral 13. yeah but there's an
error in that roman numeral i think
i think that should be
oh should it be
oh right now you're right doesn't go
alone 14 it should be six right it
should be 16. on page nine where it says
roman numeral
in in amendment
0891 it's
yeah line eight it should be
should be
16 but it's on line eight page nine
um
so
what
what i would propose
is
two so just so the clerk can keep up
we're talking about page nine starting
at line eight probably running through
line twelve is that correct that's
correct position on the page
oh it's the third it's the last one down
the last one down
um
so it and it uh and so it should uh
as i say there's a typo there it should
be section 16 but anyway what it'll the
way it will read the uh that the new
language would be
records of the youth development center
claims administration and the ydc
settlement fund
pursuant to rsa 21 m
uh 11 dash should be a small a not a
capital a but dash a
with the exception of settlement
agreements
which shall remain subject to rsa 91
a colon iv roman numeral six
and comma
after a claim has been finally resolved
such other records the release of which
would not constitute a violation of
other provisions of law
or an unwarranted invasion of a
claimant's privacy
so this and i think what what this is
designed to do is
uh in my view anyway to provide
the maximum amount of public disclosure
after the
case has been settled the maximum amount
of public disclosure
as would be allowable under law
and
and balancing
you know against the claimant's right to
privacy so i would i would assume for
example that
absent really extraordinary
circumstances a claimant's name would be
redacted would not be released to the
public
so if i were to talk to a layman
constituent i i would explain this
tell me if this is a good explanation or
not that that what we're trying to do is
conform as closely as we can to the 91 a
provisions
for public disclosure but that we
recognize
that these cases occurred and when the
victim was a juvenile
and that they're
because of such a sensitive area and
because they were a juvenile we have to
make sure that their privacy rights are
also protected but we are trying to
respect 91a is is that would that be
accurate no that that's exactly accurate
so for example as you say because
there's another that's why the other
reference to other provisions of law
because
under one under the juvenile
laws
rsa 169b
the records of the juvenile case are
sealed pursuant to statute those are not
available
pursuant to statute but there may
presumably in a case
you know that has been resolved there
may be other records that would
that would not be subject to that uh
restriction and that would be
uh if if not prohibited by some other
provision of law and if doesn't if it
doesn't uh
uh constitute an unwarranted invasion of
privacy then those records could be
could be disclosed so i think i think
you're the way you described it is
accurate
thank you so much chase did you look
like you wanted to say something
oh okay one thing that i want the
committee to be aware of is that because
there are two different
sides to the coin here that there is a
the civil process with this settlement
bill proposed there is also a criminal
side to this and the attorney general is
prosecuting a bunch of the people
involved to the extent that the the
information
is relevant to the criminal case then it
would be flood gates are completely open
the cases the case law in from the
supreme court in the united states and
here in new hampshire
is pretty strong in terms of disclosing
information you know the main case on
point from the u.s supreme court
involved a juvenile in a juvenile case
in alaska so there is precedent for the
un the idea that whatever happens here
even if there is some attempt to protect
it it's not going to stay protected
especially if it somehow has any impact
on the criminal case so i just want the
committee to be aware of that in terms
of the limitations of uh confidentiality
so so have you seen the languages
drafted by representative lynn are you
have you looked at that yes and i think
that that language is uh exactly right i
i think that the thing that i was
pointing out was other provisions of law
could also include constitutional
discovery obligations pursuant to the
criminal case so but i'm sure judge lynn
knew that so
yeah i'll i'll remind him later about
the constitutional issue
so um mr attorney general i assume you
also have this language in front of you
and and what are your comments
yeah i i think it's it's a point well
taken that there there could be
information that
that is relevant to a criminal case and
would have to be turned over to the
defense i i do think that that still
would provide some
greater level of control than making it
subject to 91a so that's that's right
not the same as just say the concord
monitor asking for the records and and
getting them within five days you know
we may have to turn it over to the
defense it may get into the public realm
because of that eventually but but it
would be a more controlled at least
orderly process i'd also just
we should keep in mind that there will
be a lot of folks who come through this
process for who
we never could have charged their cases
because past the statute of limitations
or we we couldn't we couldn't put
together enough of a case to bring
charges so
while there will be some whose records
might be relevant to a criminal case
there will be many whose records will
not be related to to a to a criminal
case so um but but we will keep that in
mind and that that is a factor that
committee should be aware of so so this
language as proposed by representative
lynn
yes or no you can live with this or not
oh yes yeah representative lynn and i
had talked about it so yes no i just
wanted to make for the record yes okay
and then represent umber did you have
something
uh
i just wanted to agree that we all
recognize that some of these
claimants may in fact end up on the
criminal side
you know not not them themselves but
their records oh right yeah could end up
over on the criminal side
and that's
that's it
so do you
have another comment it looked like you
might represent no no no no i was just i
thought you were gonna you know ready
i'm not sensing any opposition is there
any is there any opposition to accepting
this language as a substitute for the
public transparency part of the bill
i'm i'm not seeing any so represent
walnut i don't want to assume
okay so let's do that let's let's have a
working group include that
the next thing up uh we're getting
really close to being done there was an
issue related to
the ownership of the development of the
guidelines
and
you know who ultimately
um would it would how we would
coordinate them
how we would approve them and how they
would be forwarded to the joint fiscal
committee
representative lin did you have any
language on that part
i did and i this is what um
we just we had discussed this a little
bit earlier with regard to the
plaintiff's proposed
language and um as i mentioned that uh
the
i i think that that although
the attorney general ought to get input
you know and give very serious
consideration to what the claimant's
counsel
has to say
with respect to the guidelines
it should be
the attorney general that has the
ultimate authority
to develop uh and present the guidelines
to the joint uh fiscal committee um
uh
and the claims process and so the the
the change um to section four
that that
page number and line number please yes
sure it's page
three of the uh
of amendment uh
891 h online uh beginning on line 11
and running to line 24.
and and most of the changes really in
the first the first
line really are the first two lines so
this would say section 4a
as soon as practical uh following the
effective date of this section the
attorney general with input from
claimants counsel
shall develop and present to the joint
fiscal committee a claims process
consistent with this section including
the development of claims form claim
forms identification of
uh
necessary or helpful documentation
and guidelines for valuing claims for
settlement purposes which take into
account consideration of it should be of
the following factors
and then from there on
the the factors
are
uh the same as uh appear in
the uh
in sections one through four of the uh
of the of the amendment you know the
previous amendment
so so as i understand what you're what
you're
doing with this proposal is on line 11
and line 12 it says that the claimant's
counsel and the attorney general
including the advocates shall develop
and present and what you're doing is
you're clarifying
that
the attorney general is ultimately
responsible for what gets submitted to
the joint fiscal committee and that
receipt of all the appropriate input
should should be a prerequisite to that
so we're we're modifying kind of who who
owns this process
exactly it's it's it's really i mean
subject to the fiscal committee uh
ultimately but but it's the attorney
general
that makes the decision the
recommendation recommendation yes uh
representative
yeah i certainly don't want to leave out
the um
victim with witness advocates
in here because i i think they play a
very vital role
and so i'd like to
have them back into this statement
did representative lin's language delete
the advocates no it did it did it
but you're right i don't disagree with
that at all i think you're right all
right
representative walter
thank you
i'm i'm really concerned about the
fiscal committee part of this having
spent a couple of years on the physical
committee over the years
i'm not sure that the expertise is there
to really
make um
sound
decisions about this but also as i read
this and
judge lynn can help me read it more
more carefully
um
it says that they shall be developed and
presented to the fiscal committee
but it doesn't say anything about
the approval of the fiscal committee so
is this just a
to let us know what they are
i would feel differently about it
if that's what it was is just
information to the fiscal committee
no i think i i i mean you raise a you
raise a very good point which would i
mean the language should i my i
envisioned that this would require
approval by the fiscal committee
but you raise a good point if the
language doesn't say that and that needs
to be i think it's just down on line 20.
oh that's further down
is it further down yeah it's further
about that i was just reading all right
i'm sorry i was just reading the show it
was just handed out
okay representative
did you have a follow-up are you no
wait wait wait a second representative
are you done
well i i just am concerned about the
fiscal committee being
i mean most of the people a lot of the
people in this room have served on the
fiscal committee or at least
watched it in action
and
often there can be a lot of delays
things get tabled
they don't come off the table for
several meetings
i'm really concerned about the fiscal
committee
ending up with the final decision here
when
the experts in this field have put
together
the
process
and those are my concerns representative
umber yeah um
represent walnut i
i i'm like i agree okay
but
what we were i think looking for was
some sort of legislative review
and
i didn't want to have
it have to go to
a senate
committee
and a house committee
and
get voted on or or whatever
so if there's some other joint committee
that you think would be better
i'll be more than happy to give it to
them
they may not want it that's my point
but
i was simply looking for a way
that we had
both sides of the house
to be able to take a look at it
and
makes because they are going to be
reporting back to the fiscal committee
on how they're spending the money
uh what the
what the claims are you know how many
sexual abuse how many fiscal abuse
and that'll be coming every uh every
quarter
so i just felt that
it was a
it was a better place than many all
even though i'm
in full agreement that if somebody else
wants to take it let me know
since i remember the primary principle
we were after was that
there should just be some legislative
input or inclusion
because we represent the representatives
of the people and this entire
program is is going to spend the
people's money and and that there should
be some transparency in the process so
to me
this this seemed to make sense as a way
to ensure
uh public involvement
because it's such a big deal
okay
so i guess the other question i would
have and i'm sorry i wasn't on the right
i was just reading off the piece of
paper that was handed to us
i guess i would wonder about
whether it's looking for a up or down
from the fiscal committee an approval or
a non-approval
or
other things that happen at physical
is fiscal going to be able
to in some way
modify
what's presented to us
well i don't think that's been written
down my my my belief as i've listened to
this and thought about this is that the
joint fiscal committee would would take
an up or down vote just like we do on
every proposal presented by the uh
executive branch
uh and and we don't have the authority
to do any direct modifications if we for
some reason we wanted to table or vote
no
that would be a signal to the attorney
general and to the public to to take
another look at what they've presented
us and i i don't imagine that scenario
playing out but i do think the
legislation should anticipate you know
how we would handle that i i would be in
favor of a yes or no as opposed to
making this an item of information but
that's that's just my position
if i could if you look down at line 29
it does say
if the joint fiscal committee votes to
object
to the proposed claims process and
guidelines
the fiscal committee shall articulate
its reasons for objections
in writing
and the claimants counsel
and the attorney general shall present
approval
for approval of revised version
so i mean it it basically says that the
fiscal committee can reject it i can't
imagine why
but um
it can be rejected
i you know i i mean
i don't care
i just i just
didn't want it to get bogged down
some other place it's what i'm what i'm
concerned about
representative owen do you know okay and
so the joint fiscal committee at least
is logical in the sense that it's
efficient because it has the senate and
the house both participating
and uh and it is it does have a
financial implication
although the details are legal and
beyond us uh i agree with that point
i do have one
uh representative hatch yeah thank you
mr chair i'm just thinking um we've
given a lot of authority on the
front end of all this in a lot of
control within the attorney general and
and i'm sure
i'm sorry appropriately so
um
and so it goes to the fiscal committee
and as
uh representative walner pointed out
there's a lot of things that can happen
there
and not all of them necessarily
to add to the flow of what we're trying
to accomplish here
so
why would it be out of order i guess in
the context of it goes to the fiscal
committee they can have a vote and in
case of a negative vote is there a
mechanism for
the
actors
that had made the settlement to go
forward if that negative vote is not
within a certain period of time or
are not clear enough um
and and i i haven't had time to think of
this through so much but in the terms of
gelcard joint legislative committee
a department can go forward with some of
the rules even though um under the
objection of
gel card and there is a mechanism for
that to be clawed back i mean i don't
know i just
maybe i'm complicating things but no no
it's it's all good thought um i i
i it seems to me like it wouldn't take
long to get this on the fiscal
committee's calendar because the fiscal
committee meets so regularly
so i don't i don't imagine a a big delay
uh in terms of
uh having the settlements take place
without an approved set of guidelines i
think
that would defeat the purpose of the
review i mean if if i mean as assuming
that the joint fiscal committee is
competent and is actually truly a
representative of the public
then
um
it's okay to me if the public's
representative says time out we've got
an issue with this i don't imagine that
happening but it it it could
and but i don't think that scenario is
necessarily a bad one
you have commented that or
because it looks like you're thinking
there you got your thinking mask on i am
and along with what the attorney general
wanted to accomplish initially is as he
wanted separation in
or somebody wanted to
be assured that the complainants
understand that this
is not a state
per se oversight and the system isn't
rigged against them so to speak and if
you're bringing it back around to that
same body
um
i don't know what the
the look is but any i'll have to think
on it i'm sorry
again i think that's a fair thought it's
a good thought because you're trying to
make sure that people have confidence in
the system but i imagine these
guidelines need to be developed before
we unleash the settlement process on the
public and so
there isn't there there won't be an
issue i don't think and i'll let the
attorneys general correct me i i don't
think there will be an issue
of getting people all ginned up to start
working the process until after the
guidelines have been approved anyways
yeah i i would agree with that because i
think
claimants are going to want to see what
the guidelines look like before they
decide to even embark on the process so
not that they won't want to see us move
quickly which we will do but but i i
would agree that there won't there would
not be a push to kind of move forward
without guidelines
okay so because we still have plaintiffs
counsel in the room uh what what we've
done
if we if we go forward with this is all
we've done
is we've shifted
the
co-responsibility
between
the the the public and the attorneys
general
before this goes to joint committee
we've changed that from being like
co-equal
to making sure
that there's sort of a unity of command
principle in place here that there's
actually
somebody accountable for delivering
something to the fiscal committee when
everyone's responsible nobody's
responsible so this this clarifies
responsibility do you do you have
concerns about that
yes
so the the one thing that i would point
out is that this is an unusual uh legal
creature
most of the cases that involve mass tort
litigation
are agreements between the parties and
usually it occurs after what are called
bell weather trials so for example i had
a case with my client had a vaginal mesh
issue there was a multi-district
litigation going on in the vaginal mesh
cases and they had bellwether trials and
it was the
leverage that was granted to the
plaintiff's parties that helped them
craft the what are called the damage
matrix this is what we're talking about
so
this is the entire thing if this does
not work for the the plaintiffs then the
system won't work and so one thing that
i i thought of in listening to the
debate here is that
without some obligation that the the
plaintiff's counsel and the attorney
general are in agreement
then
the there's a real threat to the entire
bill
as a system of resolving these claims
and again it goes back to the fact that
this is a statutory beast as opposed to
the settlement of multiple claims after
a trial in court the
the leverage that's there to get the
parties to negotiate in
in at you know somewhat equal grounds is
gone because of the way that either
representative lin's amendment or the
bill itself as it's currently proposed
the leverage is not there to to make
sure or
to help incentivize the two sides to
come together um so for example if
instead of
representative
yeah instead of in representative lin's
language as soon as practical the
following effective date of the section
the attorney general and and strikeout
with input from in agreement with the
claimant's counsel i think that means
that their
the statute would create
some of the leverage that
exists in these multi-district
litigation cases out in the you know
non-statutory
universe
otherwise
there is a i mean this is the damage
matrix be clear is the whole thing if
the damage matrix is not done correctly
then it the the incentive
process or the incentive of the entire
uh settlement bill falls away
mr chair if i may i usually do this
to myself with myself my own brain every
time after i talk to tony what tony's
referencing just to be clear i have to
dumb it down for myself
the guidelines is the damage matrix and
while this is not a new phenomenon like
mass torts multi-district litigation
these mass tort settlement funds happen
all over the country in all different
kinds of contexts in our research we
were only able to find one statutorily
instituted compensation fund and that
was the 911 victims compensation fund
which was an act of congress that was on
the federal level so no state has done
this before i just wanted to give that
context to all the other stuff tony said
oh yeah yeah you know you know i i
appreciate what attorney skelombrini and
uh and and counsel for the uh
association for justice have said but
i i do think that this
that
the attorney general should retain this
authority to have to make the
the final decision to to us because
the
the attorney i mean
presumably the attorney general has not
gone through all this process to come up
with a you know a
a matrix of of uh guidelines that are
going to be
that are you know are not going to be
receptive to
uh to
claim its council there were no reason
no no reason for him to do that and it
would just be forcing people into the
to go into court and so i i i don't see
that happening i do see however if it's
if if the requirement is agreement
then you're going to be back to that
situation of you know of needing to have
another
administrator or another adjudicator to
this uh because if they don't if they
don't agree
so i i just think it that it it's much
better to leave this in the hands of the
attorney general he's a public figure i
think we can
i think we can rely on him doing
his uh doing a good a good job that's
fair to both sides
i i i appreciate those comments um
mr dean mr hayden did you did you want
to chime in on this because i'm getting
ready to do a straw vote i just want to
make sure you're heard
thank you all
don't go away we might have more
i would
just like to add i mean the last
subcommittee meeting
there was a discussion in
by dave
visananza who's actually been through
this process
a number of times
on the defense side
and you know what dave
says this time and time again is this
whole
um
determination of the guidelines is a
very it's a it's a brutal process
because you both sides really need to
confront very difficult facts and
circumstances and trying to try to work
through them
i would say
you know i offered that mediator
earlier as a way of sort of helping the
attorney general and and us get through
the process if it was needed and i would
say
if this amendment is used
um you know you're really taking out the
you're turning it into a one-sided
process and and i don't see how this
will help the process of getting to
acclaim's
guidelines at all
so
so mr dean do you want to
add or amplify or
argue maybe you could disagree with him
no i no i agree with him and
um
i agree with the comment comments
previously as well um you know we um
i think it's been a common theme we've
we've said throughout um and dave has
said many times that this is all about
trust and
um this
would clearly be
um
a difficult hurdle uh for for us in
talking to our clients uh and giving
them trust in going into the system um
you know
i i feel like if they know their counsel
are
getting a seat at the table that's
co-equal with the attorney general in in
hashing out guidelines that
that they think will be fair that
that'll go a long way
representative berger thank you
um
i certainly hear where you're coming
from
though
the step
what we have written right now is i
think we give the attorney general six
months
to come up with the guidelines wasn't
that the
criteria
it's i think it was someplace along in
there
yeah i think it's well it's as soon as
practical in the first instance but i
there's an overall deadline of december
one by which that notice has to get
published so right it probably ends up
roughly being six months to get yeah
because this is uh
goes into effect on passage
so when when do you throw up your hands
and say
i can't agree
since we have
the one december deadline to notify
people
you know do you do it on the 29th of of
um
november
or you know
if if we are an agreement on 90 of the
stuff
is that not okay
you know it's just like as we have gone
through the legislation
you know
the
the group has accepted
a lot of your language
the a jesus accepted a lot of the
language that dave and
provided so
i think you know or think you understand
that
we are willing to to compromise
but
i need to know you know
how how do we get to the six months
how do we how do we
get to the six months if
we don't have one person in one agency
in charge that's where that's where my
concern is because
i'm telling you i'm not going to give
the ag
any slack on this
which means i wouldn't give you any
slack either
but
that's the date
and i think that all of us
are
passionate about getting this
going but if you don't like an and or an
or
and you know and that becomes your issue
you know then
how do we move forward with the deadline
and i i don't you know i'm just using
that as an example
is that a a question or a rhetorical
question well
i guess that's a question
okay
do you care to respond well
to go back to what to what jim said i
mean i think the answer is
uh yeah we negotiate and uh that's why
we like the idea of a mediator and it
doesn't have to be the administrator to
be somebody completely different
um we can you can set a date for our
mediation you know we can negotiate
ahead of that mediation to get
90 of the issues done um and then we've
got that last nugget and
i mean we um you know i'm sure the
attorney general's been to many
mediations uh
uh you know there's a lot of incentive
to get it done
um on that day
follow-up yes follow-up
i guess i would
i would prefer
not to put that in the legislation
because that gives you an
incentive not to me not
not to agree because you know
that mediation is going to occur
however if uh the ag
and you at some point in time are
knocking heads he can
he has the authority to do what he needs
to do
to make sure
that he meets that deadline
so i would
i would prefer that we just
leave it out so so i i can't get out of
my military mindset on this is that as a
legislature responsible for crafting
this
we have to worry about
accountability and we can hold the
attorney general accountable for
delivery of the results we cannot hold
the public accountable for delivery of
the results
so so as an agent of the state
the attorney general has all the
incentives that he could have i think
to to make the uh the the
the guidelines
fair agreeable acceptable
and
but at the end of the day somebody's
going to have to decide
what are we going to do
and as a member of the public if it
comes to the joint fiscal committee you
still have recourse
so it isn't like the attorney general
can make a decision without it being
subject to legislative review anyway so
i
i i i'd like to call a straw vote uh i'm
i'm going to vote
uh in favor of um
representative lin's language around
this uh you you you can make some minor
modifications to make sure the language
works and everything but but so so what
i'd like to do with the straw vote
is if you're in favor of of
representative lin's language
substantially as as written on this
extra handout
then you will raise your hand and if
you're opposed you'll raise your hand on
the second vote
and and if the second vote prevails
we'll discuss it further
so um all those in favor of
accepting
the the lynn proposal and ask the
working group to come back with their
language in the bill please raise your
hand
those opposed raise your hand
i think three we got represent
three it's just hard to see cause the
chairs are in the way
uh okay so so seven to three we'll we'll
do that um
okay then the next item i had was
making sure that thank you uh making
sure there's a sunset date
so that the law can self-close and and i
guess the working group's gonna do that
because it's got to be in the ols
version yes and then
i wrote a note something about retired
judge language there was something about
if you selected a retired judge then the
retirement issue
do we need to write language on that
yes
yes and uh
mike and kevin have that already
okay so we take care of it so with that
i i think we've force marched through
all the items that we had for today are
there any last calls by anyone out in
the audience
any last calls by the committee
okay so in my rece i'm recessing this
right okay so with that uh we're going
to recess the hearing on uh hb
and we will reconvene
thursday march 3rd at 2 p.m probably in
this room
[Music]
okay if you're on division 3 stick
around because we're still going to talk
about hp 103.
finished
mr ripple
miss ripple
did did you hand out the ols
change document
all right
okay i'm going to um
call the hearing on hb 103 back into
order
um
the reason the reason we're doing this
is because
we we had ols turn around for us
very rapidly an amendment
that you should have
2022-0
hotel
does everyone have that version
okay
in this version
we added a sentence
that shows up on line eight at the end
that sentence runs through line ten it
reads
in addition the general court recognizes
that personal responsibility is an
essential component of any strategy to
improve individual oral health
is there
didn't seem like there was any objection
prior if there is
please speak up
then i think we go down to
[Music]
line
it's it's in it's in that area between
lines 19 and 22 on the first page
and what did we add here mr ripple it
looks like we added
fostering individual behaviors that
promote good oral health
yes yep on line 21
on line 21
was that the only change in the sentence
yes it was i think it is okay
then
again if you know speak up if you have
any opposition to this um
so then we go down to line
so i can if you'd like i can point this
28 go ahead walk us through
i know i'm sorry on line 29 you've added
patient education
to the list of the
states estate's requirements right and
then the same on page two
line six
okay and and so that just made sure that
the framework included those concepts
because we already had it embedded
in the details of the contract
where
we we said that
they needed to receive
education for behavior management and
smoking succession counseling
so so there wasn't a substantive change
it was just making sure that it was
more clear that personal responsibility
matters
is there any discussion on those changes
no
okay
so what i would like to do is to um
do do we need to take a role on this
since we're going to recommend to the
full finance committee a position on
this bill
yes yes
okay so so i would entertain
a motion
to accept uh amendment
0904 hotel so i moved
second
second by representative walner
okay
amendment
zero nine zero four h
2 0
2 2 sorry ken at the beginning this is 3
the bill is hb 103
and
so so is there any discussion before the
vote
saying none would the clerk take a roll
yes
chairman edwards yes
six to zero
all right uh okay so uh it passes uh
thank you so much for sticking around uh
dr finney did you stick around just to
hear a six to nothing vote
that i didn't screw it up at the end
all right so with that uh the hearing on
hb 103 fn
is
closed nice
you